Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio 207 live aus der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Und heute ist es ein ganz besonderes Chaos Radio, das ich moderieren darf. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Hallo. Und zwar, wenn es ein Foto geben, also so ein Stockfoto für die heutige Sendung, dann würden das wahrscheinlich die meisten Mainstream-Medien so darstellen, dass vor einer Tastatur jemand mit einer Skimütze sitzen würde und da ganz, ganz, ganz fies da reinhackt. Und dahinter noch jemand, der so eine weiße Skimütze auf hat und den auf einer anderen Tastatur hinterherhackt. Wir reden nämlich heute hier über Professional Hackers und geben einen Einblick in die Security-Industrie. Das klingt jetzt alles ganz schlimm, schlagzeilenmäßig, aber das Ziel der heutigen Sendung ist tatsächlich mal wegzugehen von dem skandalisierten Blick auf Sicherheitsexperten, die immer nur dann gefragt werden, wenn irgendwo ein Kernkraftwerk explodiert, sondern einfach mal auch zeigen, dass dieses Ding, was da Menschen mit Computern arbeitet, wo es um Sicherheitslücken geht und darum Software sicher zu machen oder sicher zu halten, dass es halt einfach auch ein Beruf ist. Ein gefährlicher, wie wir dann auch im zweiten Teil der Sendung noch sehen würden, aber halt einer, den man halt einfach auch arbeiten kann. Und deswegen begrüße ich jetzt ganz herzlich viele Leute, die genau in dieser Branche arbeiten und die sich jetzt mal alle selber vorstellen müssen, weil ich ganz vergessen habe vorher zu fragen, ob sie lieber mit ihrem Synonym genannt, Pseudonym genannt werden wollen oder mit dem richtigen Namen. Mir zu linken sitzt...
Ich? Ich bin freundlicher. Ja, ich arbeite auch in dieser Branche.
Sehr gut.
Und daneben sitzt...
Linus.
Hallo Linus. Und rechts von mir sitzt...
Der Silvus. Hallo.
Hallo. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Fernzuschaltung auch noch netz live haben oder ob die sich noch verabschiedet hat.
Nein, ich hab mich nicht verabschiedet. Ich bin Thorsten oder THS.
Hallo Thorsten und THS. So. Und ich würde heute sagen, gerne mit all diesen Leuten drüber reden, was sie in der Security-Branche machen. Und ich möchte natürlich auch gerne wissen, wie sie da hingekommen sind. So thematisch aufgeteilt wird es so, dass wir von der Theorie in die Praxis gehen. Also wir haben ja erst den Silvus, der von Uni wegen, wo ich richtig informiert bin, damit zu tun hat, wie man Systeme theoretisch sicher macht oder hält.
Ja, genau. Ich habe das in der Vergangenheit ein wenig von der technischen Seite betreut. Heute betreue ich das ganze Thema von der management- und organisatorischen Seite. Also Leute oder gewisse Gruppen in Unternehmen sagen, unsere Systeme sind sicher. Wir haben da so ein schönes Management-System implementiert auf Basis des internationalen Standards, auf dem wir Informationssicherheit oder IT-Sicherheit betreiben, sich dann eine Selbsteinschätzung geben, wie sie sich denn selber sehen. Und dann komme ich ganz gerne vorbei und klopfe da mal mit dem Hammer ein wenig an der Fassade rum, um zu schauen, ob das Ganze dann auch Hand und Fuß hat, was die Firmen im Vorfeld über ihr Sicherheitsniveau kommuniziert haben.
Das waren viele schöne Worte. Ich habe sie nicht genau verstanden. Sag nochmal genau, was ist dein Job?
Also mein Job ist im Grunde genommen Auditor. Das Ganze auf Basis der ISO 27001, was halt ein internationaler Standard für Informationssicherheitsmanagementsysteme ist, der sich primär in drei Bereiche untergliedert. Einmal die physische Absicherung von Liegenschaften, Gebäuden, einzelnen Sicherheitsbereichen. Dann die technische Sicherheit von System, wie sichert ich diese technisch ab. Und dann noch der Bereich der organisatorischen Sicherheit, also welche Regelungen und Richtlinien gebe ich beispielsweise für Mitarbeiter vor, welche Prozesse brauche ich, welche Workflows.
Das heißt im Prinzip, das hört sich jetzt so ein bisschen an, du fasst eigentlich zu keiner Zeit wirklich an der Tastatur an, sondern das ist im Prinzip eine komplexe Checkliste, die du abarbeitest.
Nein, nicht mit einer Checkliste. Dann wären wir ja im BSI Grundschutz, sondern man lässt sich schon erklären, okay, wir haben jetzt da, sage ich mal, in Anführungszeichen für mich jetzt, ist da eine Lücke und dann frage ich erst mal nach, warum besteht denn die Lücke?
Ja, aber diese Lücke, die siehst du, weil du dir den theoretischen Aufbau des Systems anguckst, nicht die Praxis.
Ja, die Praxis auch. Also ich packe selber keine Tastatur an, sondern dafür lasse ich halt ganz gerne die Mitarbeiter im Unternehmen das Ganze machen und sage halt, zeigen sie mir mal das, zeigen sie mir mal jenes.
Genau, aber sag mal, es ist der theoretische Blick, in dem du lässt dir das System zeigen und kontrollierst, ob das theoretische, die Architektur sozusagen die richtige ist. Okay, gut. Dazu kommen wir gleich genauer. Dann kommt Linus. Linus, was machst du? So ganz kurz erstmal.
Meine Tätigkeit nennt sich IT Security Consultant.
Das hört sich schlimm an? Wenn Consultant vorkommt, denkt man so, heiße Luft.
Ja, heiße Luft eher nicht. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass man dann immer in jedem Unternehmen willkommen ist.
Was ist denn deine Aufgabe?
Also im Prinzip, das Sicherheitskonzept ist irgendwie fertig. Da ist vielleicht auch schon mal jemand drüber gegangen, der sich, wie jetzt WC was, mit solchen Konzepten auskennt und die Architektur und alles geprüft hat und sagt, okay, jetzt wollen wir mal schauen, was gibt es denn über das, was wir mit mehr oder weniger Standards und Wissen abdecken können, noch darüber hinaus zu holen an Problemen. Das heißt, da geht es dann wirklich darauf los, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt schauen wir nicht nur theoretisch mit einem Hammer, sondern jetzt nehmen wir wirklich mal einen Hammer. Dann werden halt Penetration-Tests gemacht. Dann stellt man irgendwann fest, okay, hier und da gibt es Sicherheitslücken. Die müssen wir irgendwie abfrühstücken und irgendwie beseitigen. Und dann geht es eigentlich in die Richtung zu überlegen, okay, was haben wir daraus gelernt? Können wir erkennen, was wir falsch gemacht haben als Unternehmen? Von den zum Beispiel Anreizen her oder von irgendwie Ausgaben, die wir in bestimmten Bereichen nicht getätigt haben, wo wir sie vielleicht tätigen sollten. Was müssen wir im Unternehmen auch vielleicht ändern, damit uns sowas nicht nochmal passiert?
Penetration-Test oder Pen-Test, das wird heute noch häufiger fallen, das Wort vermutlich. Du gehst halt praktisch hin und versuchst dein System kaputt zu machen. Oder aufzumachen. Also reinzukommen.
Ich mach das persönlich weniger, aber meine Mitarbeiter sind da sehr, oder meine Kollegen sind da sehr begnadet.
Aber du bist sozusagen eine Stufe praktischer als Thebas, weil du sagen nicht nur die Architektur anguckst, sondern schon nach einer konkreten Sicherheitslücke guckst und die dann von deinen Kollegen sozusagen.
Also meine Kollegen finden die Sicherheitslücken und ich arbeite dann eher mit den Leuten zusammen, denen das auch wirklich zu erklären, weil man häufig das Problem hat, wenn du jetzt einfach nur die Liste mit Sicherheitslücken den Leuten zurück gibst und sagst, in drei Wochen komm ich wieder und dann sollen die weg sein. Das klappt in der Regel nicht. Oder sie versuchen dann... Du bist der Übersetzer. Da würde ich mich am ersten sehen. Ich mache auch einige bestimmte Arten von Angriffen selber, aber die sind dann weniger technisch.
Okay, kommen wir auch noch dazu. So, dann ist da der THS. Was machst du genau?
Ja, ich sehe mich da auch so ein bisschen bei den Bereichen, die Cebas und Linus da erwähnt haben. Das heißt, auf der einen Seite mache ich eben auch solche theoretischen Sicherheitsgeschichten nur halt in einem sehr viel kleineren Stil. Wir haben dann da eher kleinere Teams, mit denen wir so Sicherheitskonzepte ausarbeiten. Und am Ende bin ich auch mehr so unterwegs wie Linus. Das heißt auch mehr so in einer übersetzenden Tätigkeit. Das heißt, ich bin halt auch Security Consultant und auch Penetration Tester, je nachdem, wie man das nennen mag. Das heißt, ich arbeite eigentlich auch sehr technisch und gehe da sehr in die Tiefe. Und auf der anderen Seite versuche ich halt den Leuten zu erzählen, warum sie bestimmte Probleme haben und wie sie die langfristig in den Griff bekommen können. Und da bin ich dann halt im Grunde genommen so unterwegs wie Linus auch. Das heißt, wir gucken, ob die Theorie und die Praxis irgendwie auseinandergehen oder ob das da halt irgendwie alles so funktioniert, wie es in der Theorie funktionieren sollte. Und schauen dann halt einfach, was die Ursachen sind. Ansonsten bin ich oder ich mit meinem Team noch mehr technisch unterwegs. Das heißt, wir gehen mehr in die Tiefe, kriegen halt auch eher so die Jobs an die Backe, wo wir halt Schwachstellen suchen sollen oder Lücken in irgendwelchen Prozessen suchen sollen. Das heißt, auf der einen Seite bekommen wir Software- oder Hardwarekomponenten vorgesetzt und sollen damit halt bestimmte Dinge tun. Also je nachdem, was für ein Bedrohungsszenario da für die entsprechenden Kunden wichtig sind. Also die einen wollen halt irgendwie verhindern, dass Geräte geklaut oder kopiert werden können. Die anderen wollen sicherstellen, dass keine unbefugten Leute Zugriff auf bestimmte Daten bekommen können. Und dann schaut man halt, wo sind die Risiken am höchsten und welche Daten sind am schützendwertesten. Und dann gehen wir da technisch in die Tiefe und versuchen dann da eben Fehler zu finden. Wenn wir da keine Fehler finden, ist das nicht, dass da keine Fehler gibt. Aber das ist halt nochmal ansetzen bekommen. Also was wir halt auch oft machen, sind halt so Tests, Sicherheitsuntersuchungen, wo wir uns so verhalten sollen, wie Kriminelle das auch tun. Einfach damit die Kunden sehen, was passiert eigentlich, wenn wir so einem Angriff tatsächlich ausgesetzt sind. Wie funktionieren dann all diese ganzen Sicherheitsprozesse und diese Sicherheitsketten und alles. Das heißt, wir machen halt auch so Red Team Pen Tests und verhalten uns dann eher auch unkonventionell und halt auch sehr speziell. Das heißt, wir bauen auch eben Angriffswerkzeuge, um Dinge zu überlisten.
Dazu kommen wir dann später noch genau. Und jetzt hat man schon gesehen, das Klischee-Bild ist ja sozusagen, alle Leute, also wenn man so hört, Sicherheits-Experten und Security Consultants, hat man immer so im Kopf genau das, was THS jetzt als letztes erzählt hat. Aber man sieht jetzt schon sozusagen, die Arbeit besteht aus viel, viel mehr und ich vermute auch viel weniger glamourös. Dann haben wir hier noch Frank auf dem Sofa. Der macht dann sozusagen die Gegenseite, wenn man so will. Erklär doch mal kurz.
Also ich bin zuständig in meinem Unternehmen für die technologische Seite von Sicherheitsprodukten. Wir versuchen Dinge ein bisschen besser und sicherer zu machen. Also dafür zu sorgen, dass die Produkte, die wir bauen, zumindest schwieriger anzugreifen sind, als man so allgemein erwartet. Wir machen halt verschiedene Dinge. Zum einen halt Verschleißungstechnologie, zum anderen bauen wir auch Systeme, mit denen man erkennen kann, ob man zum Beispiel angegriffen wird. Also verschiedene Netzwerkebenen. Und da ist halt die Herausforderung primär, keine Fehler zu machen. Also jedenfalls keine einfach vorherzusehenden Fehler zu machen. Und natürlich halt ab-to-date zu bleiben, was Angriffsmöglichkeiten, Angriffwege angeht, die auch schon vorher zu ahnen. Also zu sagen, selbst wenn es da jetzt noch keinen konkreten Angriff gibt, aus der Erfahrung heraus, wenn man da schon eine Weile in der Branche unterwegs ist, dann kann man schon so ahnen, bestimmte Arten von Software oder bestimmte Arten von Protokollen werden einfach kaputt gehen, auch wenn sie heute gerade noch nicht kaputt sind, einfach aufgrund ihrer Struktur die dann wegzulassen, beziehungsweise so abzukapseln, dass sie halt irgendwie nicht zum Problem werden. Das ist dann halt schon so weit im Vorfeld zu tun, dass man dann, wenn irgendjemand mal anfängt, auf dieser Art von Protokoll oder diesem Interface rumzuhacken, dann bei uns nichts zu holen ist.
Okay, du machst also, du versuchst es im Prinzip richtig zu machen. Versuchen kaputt zu machen? Versuchst du von vornherein richtig zu machen?
Ja, wobei natürlich dabei eine Menge Kaputtmachen dabei ist. Also insbesondere halt so die Arten von Produkten, die wir machen, haben sehr viel mit Reverse-Engineering zu tun. Also damit die Systeme sehr tiefgründig zu verstehen, um dann halt auch zu verstehen, wo die Sicherheitslücken sind und die dann ausschließen zu können. Also es beides kaputt machen und richtig machen an einem sozusagen.
Okay. Gut, das ist sozusagen jetzt, hat schon eine Viertelstunde gedauert, aber ist ja grob Überblick über die Sendung heute, mit der wir jetzt anfangen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen nochmal. Und ich würde sagen, wir machen die Runde jetzt nochmal und dann ein bisschen ausführlicher. Und ich würde gerne aber von euch allen auch wissen, wie ihr da überhaupt hingekommen seid, das zu machen, was ihr macht. Weil, wenn man so einen, wie heißt das, Professional Hacker von der Security-Industrie im Fernsehen sieht, dann denken wir so, ha, das ist dieser Professional Hacker von der Security-Industrie, der hat das quasi schon, der ist so geboren worden mit der Skimaske auf dem Kopf. C-Bars, wie wird man ISO, wie war es ISO 2007?
Nein ISO 27001.
Das werde ich bestimmt noch mal falsch machen. ISO 27001 Nachprüfer. Was ist dein Werdegang? Wie bist du überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen, das zu machen?
Ja, du fängst halt irgendwann einfach an zu sagen, okay, wir machen jetzt das Thema sicher.
Moment, du bist ja nicht auf die Welt gekommen, hast ja dann so mit 5 gedacht, jetzt machen wir mal Systeme sicher. Ich meine jetzt wirklich sozusagen von Anfang an, wo ist der Punkt gekommen, wo du gedacht hast, okay, ich möchte jetzt mit diesem System sicher machen, das könnte irgendwie was Langfristiges sein. Was ist da passiert?
Da ist viel dazwischen passiert. Aber das würde den Rahmen aufspringen, aber ich habe mich beruflich eine lange Zeit damit auseinandergesetzt, Kommunikationssysteme sicher zu gestalten und eine sichere Architektur zu erzeugen.
Aber man muss doch irgendwie anfangen. Hast du nach dem Abi direkt Informatik studiert und das war sofort eine Fachrichtung?
Nein, ich habe eine Ausbildung zum IT-Systemelektroniker gemacht, nebenher Informatik studiert und dann irgendwann für mich entschieden, Informatikstudium werde ich nicht beenden, sondern der Beruf frisst halt einfach zu viel Zeit. Und zugelassen dann halt einfach gesagt, wir sollen immer sichere Systeme bauen. Da sind zehn Leute, die sagen, die sind sicher, aber keiner guckt wirklich nach, ob es so ist. Dann habe ich für mich entschieden, ich möchte mich gerne in dem Bereich spezialisieren und weiter darauf eingehen. Und habe dann viel Zeit von Weiterbildung und Seminare gemacht, die halt in den Bereich gehen, wie man prüfen kann, dass Systeme sicher sind, welche Methoden man dazu anwenden kann, um halt dementsprechend sicherstellen zu können.
Und hast du auf diesen Weiterbildungen gelernt, wie das geht oder waren die nur dazu da, dass du quasi jetzt den Schein hast, wo du vorzeigen kannst, okay, ich weiß, was eine ISO 2791 ist? Also der Hintergrund der Frage ist der, ich habe Informatik studiert und nie richtig Programmieren gelernt. Weil für mich war das sozusagen so, im Grundstudium war das alles so relativ einfach. Und dann sozusagen mit Eintritt ins Hauptstudium wurde auf einmal erwartet, dass man natürlich weiß, wie man diverse Programmiersprachen umgeht, dass man da die Grundkonzepte kennt, etc. Das wurde auf einmal erwartet. Deswegen die Frage, lernt man dieses System Architektur überprüfen? Lernt man das in diesen Fortbildungen tatsächlich oder muss man das schon können?
Das musst du schon können.
Wo lernt man das denn?
Das kannst du auch durch Seminare und Weiterbildung lernen oder halt im Hauptstudium.
In meinem Hauptstudium nicht. Aber du hast das gesagt, dass du tätig auf die Zeltsoberseminare sagst.
Richtig, ich hab noch weitere Seminare gemacht und ich halt mit Architektur-Schaubildern oder Architekturaufbau, wie sich Architekturlandschaften noch gestalten können, wo da Risiken sind, durch Seminare halt weitergebildet und halt durch Praxiserfahrung. Was man so an eigenen Fehlern gemacht hat beim Aufbau solcher Architektur.
Ich frag gerade, was war deine erste Praxiserfahrung?
Meine erste Praxiserfahrung war, als wir eine First-in-Last-out-Kommunikationslösung aufgebaut haben, dass man dann doch einige Sachen vergessen hat in der Absicherung und dann doch nicht das erzielte Ergebnis.
Was war das bei der Kommunikationslösung?
Satellitenkommunikation.
Okay, und dann ist da jemand reingegrätscht oder hat dir dann jemand gezeigt, okay, jetzt hast du aber ganz schön viel falsch gemacht?
Da waren ganz schön viele Fehler noch drin, ja. Genau.
Aber sind die dir auf den Fuß gefallen, weil wirklich was schief gegangen ist?
Nee, der ist im Vorfeld bei Evaluierungstests halt einfach auf den Fuß gefallen. Und dementsprechend konnte man die Fehler noch beheben. Und ich bin dann dazu übergegangen zu sagen, ja, wenn viele sagen, ja, das funktioniert, dann sollte auch nochmal jemand drauf gucken, ob es wirklich funktioniert, ja.
Vertrauen sie mir.
Ja, genau, Vertrauen ist gut, Kontrolle ist besser. Und deshalb habe ich für mich entschieden, so, ja, es ist schön, wenn man weiß, wie man es baut, sollte nochmal jemand drauf gucken und dann Haken hinter machen.
Und du bist aber jetzt jemand, der wird von außen gerufen.
Genau.
Eine Firma glaubt, okay, wir haben ein sicheres System. Und dann sagt jemand, naja, das will ich aber mal genau wissen.
Richtig.
Was machst du dann?
Dann muss die Firma erstmal eine Selbstbewertung abgeben. Also so eine Selbsteinschätzung in verschiedenen Bereichen. Es kommt drauf an, wo der Kunde den Schwerpunkt legt, ob er jetzt sagt, wir würden gerne nur die Technik uns bewerten lassen oder begutachten lassen und dann zugehörig noch die Prozesse und Workflows, die hinterlegt sind. Und dann werden die den Bereich halt für sich erstmal bewerten. Da gibt es verschiedene Bewertungstabellen, die man da zur Hand ziehen kann und Risikoanalyse machen, wo die sich selbst einstufen. Und dann schaut man sich die Einschätzung an und kann sich einen groben Überblick verschaffen, fordert dann dazu noch gewisse Architekturshow-Bilder an, spricht mit den Leuten im Vorfeld, um so ein grobes Konzept zu entwickeln, wie man die Architektur jetzt prüfen möchte und fährt dann halt eben vor Ort und schaut sich das Ganze vor Ort an.
Was heißt das, man schaut sich vor Ort an? Ich glaube, du stehst dann sozusagen in einem Anzug, schön seriös aussehend.
Genau, so bin ich heute noch nach Berlin gefahren, bevor ich mich habe umgezogen, schön seriös im Anzug und stelle dann Fragen. Also ich versuche die Gesprächsrunden immer erst mal so zu gestalten, dass ich mich erst mal mit dem Management hinsetze, zu verstehen, was ist deren Konzept, wo soll die Reise hingehen, welche Absichten haben die und dann im zweiten Atemzug halt mit den Leuten aus der Technik nur zu sprechen, um da halt auch kein Ungleichgewicht zu haben bzw. relativ viel Gesprächsfreiraum zu haben, weil es hat sich rausgestellt, so ein Techniker spricht dann doch eher mit einem, wenn keiner von Management dabei ist.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Das ist aber, das passiert alles mit diesen Gesprächsrunden. Du fragst im Prinzip Dinge ab, die mir aufgefallen sind.
Richtig. Lass mir Dokumente zeigen, was jetzt genau für eine Technologie verbaut worden ist, verwendet worden ist. Schau mir die Systeme halt an mit einem Architekturberater, den die Unternehmen meist haben. Also ein Softwarearchitekten oder Netzwerkarchitekten, der mir das dann erläutert, wie man zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, das so aufzubauen und sagt dann an folgenden Stellen, geh ich aber nicht mit der Core, da ist zu wenig getan worden, um wirklich Sicherheit erzeugt zu haben.
Das hört sich aber alles sehr theoretisch an, also glauben die die Leute das dann einfach?
Na im Regelfall nicht, weil Management sagt natürlich immer, wir haben ja schon genügend Geld investiert, das kann ja alles gar nicht so teuer werden, also IT darf ja kein Geld kosten, vor allem nicht IT-Sicherheit, weil du arbeitest halt mit einem Thema, was für Leute halt schwer greifbar ist. Das ist halt alles virtuell irgendwie abgebildet und somit für die Leute schlecht greifbar und sehr unverständlich.
Aber ist es so, wenn du dann geholt wirst, hast du manchmal die Ahnung, du bist so eine Art Feigenblatt? Also du wirst da einmal drüber gelaufen lassen, wenn du sagst, okay das stimmt jetzt nach dieser ISO-Ding so oder andersrum gefragt. Du prüfst so ein System auf diese ISO. Wenn das das alles erfüllt, heißt das automatisch, dass es sicher ist?
Nein. 100 Prozent Sicherheit gibt es nie. Es ist ja dann eher die Empfehlung, man sagt so, man kann es unter der Berücksichtigung, also unter den verschiedenen Faktoren, die mit reinspielen, kann man das System sicher erachten. Wenn man dann eine Schwachstelle findet, holt man dann Leute wie Thorsten oder Linus halt noch ins Boot und lässt halt das System nochmal vom Pentester gegen verschiedene Parameter einfach laufen, um zu gucken, ob da noch Schwachstellen sind.
Ist das nicht frustrierend? Auf Dauer, würde ich sagen? Man guckt immer, man sagt immer und dann wird es einem quasi nicht geglaubt. Genau.
Und im zweiten Art und Zuge geht es halt dann daran, wenn man den Bericht halt geschrieben hat und die Auswertung gemacht hat mit den Pentestern zusammen, auch für Akzeptanz beim Management halt einfach nochmal zu werben, auch nochmal Budget freizugeben, um Systeme dann auch wirklich sicher zu bekommen.
Also ich glaube in keiner Branche der Informatik ist die Tendenz zu, lieber was mit Holz oder Orchideen so groß wie bei den Security Pentestern.
Ich stell's mir halt hier nochmal extra frustrierend vor, weil als Pentester, der es praktisch macht, kannst du ja nochmal nachweisen, wir haben halt hier reingeguckt und dann stell ich mir das vor, wir klären uns gleich noch genau, aber bei dir ist es ja eher so, das ist ja eine theoretische Arbeit. Also von dem, was ihr mir hier erzählt, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, da wird irgendwas kaputt gehen und wenn die dann sagen, das ist schön und gut, vielen Dank, tschüss, dann ist es so.
Damit musst du halt einfach leben. Also du weißt im Grunde genommen bei 80 Prozent deiner Mandanten, dass da noch viel zu tun ist. Ob man die Leute erreicht hat und die nötige Awareness wecken konnte, da weiter vorzugehen, ist halt die zweite Frage.
Also ganz oft ist es ja dann auch so, dass die Leute sagen, ja, ist ja schön und gut, dass sie herausgefunden haben, dass dies oder jenes potenziell unsicher ist, aber wir haben kein Budget dafür.
Wow, also bestes Beispiel, ich hab jetzt zwei Jahre lang in meinem Job eine Statistik geführt über gebrochene Zutrittssysteme, die halt noch in der Wirtschaft unterwegs sind, also Schießsysteme, elektronische und ich muss sagen, bei der Auswertung sind erschreckende Zahlen rausgekommen. Also 70 Prozent der Systeme, die bei Unternehmen im Einsatz sind, sind so gebrochen, dass du mit einem Gerät, wo du die Schießkarte halt mit deinem Telefon im Grunde genommen kopieren kannst, kannst das Signal der Karte aufnehmen, den Schlüssel kopieren und dir so mit Zutritt zu einem Unternehmen verschaffen, ohne dass es jemand mitbekommt und den Unternehmen ist es teilweise wirklich egal, wenn man es ihnen sagt und es sind keine kleinen Unternehmen, wo kein Kapital zur Verfügung steht, das Ganze zu ändern. Nein, da sind noch große Konzerne dabei.
Bis jemand kommt und das demonstriert, erst dann wird eben Budget für solche neuen Sicherheitsmechanismen oder irgendein Update auch bereitgestellt. Also das ist halt so, dass die Penetration-Tester dann kommen und im Grunde genommen die Leute dabei unterstützen, das Budget für ihre Sicherheit zu erhöhen.
Warte mal, ich verstehe es richtig. Also sie kaufen dich ein, damit du theoretisch drauf guckst, ob was sicher ist. Wenn du sagst, dass es nicht sicher ist, wird, bevor Geld dafür ausgegeben wurde, sicher zu machen, wird nochmal Geld ausgegeben, um zu zeigen, dass es wirklich nicht sicher ist.
Genau.
Also ich finde das jetzt ein bisschen überzogen. Also das Unternehmen ist ja nicht da, um sicher zu sein, sondern das Unternehmen ist da, um Geld zu verdienen. Entsprechend haben die natürlich auch ein Fokus darauf. Und wenn sie jetzt irgendwie etwas Neues machen oder so, also irgendwie ein Produkt rausbringen oder ein Mobilfunknetz bauen zum Beispiel oder irgendwas, dann wollen natürlich erstmal, dass dieses Ding funktioniert. Und IT-Sicherheit hat immer so dieses Problem, dass es potenziell unendlich viel kosten kann und man nichts für dieses Geld bekommt, außer dass man Geld nicht verliert. Und das ist immer schwierig zu verargumentieren. Das heißt, wenn du eine gute Sicherheitsabteilung hast, die du mit viel Geld bezahlst, dann wirst du am Ende des Jahres auf diese Sicherheitsabteilung blicken und sagen, hm, die machen mir den ganzen Tag nur Ärger. Die gehen in jedes neue Geschäftsfeld rein, was ich habe, in jedes neue Produkt, was ich auf den Markt bringen will, und verderben mir den Spaß. Die sorgen dafür, dass sich der Projektplan verzögert, weil die dann irgendwann sagen, ja so und so könnte er das nicht machen, dann müsste er noch hier was machen. Und dann kommen meine Projektmanager zu mir und sagen, ey, diese Sicherheitshainis sind wieder da und ich kann meinen versprochenen Milestones irgendwie nicht halten oder so. Das ist der Ruf, den eine funktionierende Abteilung IT-Sicherheit im größeren Unternehmen, unter dem sie leidet. Gleichzeitig merken die aber auch, oh, das wäre aber schlecht, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie ein Problem bekommen. Da kommt dann der Cevas, der sich wahrscheinlich, wie jetzt auch an dem Beispiel Schließsysteme, dann auch erstmal um die Sicherheit des Unternehmens als solches bemüht. Also wie sind eure Türen? Habt ihr irgendwie vernünftige Smartcarts oder ist das irgendwie was, was in den neunziger Jahren irgendwie als Treppenwitz gehandelt wird? Habt ihr irgendwie, wie geht ihr mit sicheren, mit vertraulichen Daten um oder so? Also seid ihr als Unternehmen erstmal sicher? Und dann kommt so eine zweite Teil, wo man vielleicht sagt, okay, das Unternehmen hat jetzt ein Produkt oder eine Dienstleistung oder so und will einen bestimmten Teil seines Geschäftsfeldes nochmal genauer prüfen lassen. Also ich mach das hauptsächlich im Bereich von Mobilfunknetzen, also Mobilfunktechnologien, alles was da so zum Einsatz kommt. Das können also die Netze selber sein, das kann der der Management-Teil des Netzes sein, das können auch bestimmte Apps sein auf irgendwelchen, die irgendwie irgendwo für gebaut werden. Und all das unterliegt immer dem Druck, möglichst natürlich schnell am Markt zu sein.
Und kostengünstig.
Und nicht zu viel Geld zu kosten, damit man irgendwie damit Geld verdienen kann. Aber trotzdem ist es ja so, dass das Unternehmen dann weiß, okay, wir müssen irgendwie zusehen, dass uns das nicht auf die Füße fällt. Und dann bestellt man sich also die Consultants oder die Pentester ins Haus und sagt, okay, könnt ihr uns mal kurz helfen, dass das sicher ist? Und in der Regel muss man dann erst mal so ein, zwei Tage mit denen zusammensitzen und sagen so, welche Geschmacksrichtung von sicher meint ihr? Und was sind überhaupt Bedrohungsszenarien für euer Produkt oder eure Infrastruktur? Also was ist das, was irgendwie ein Schwanzrisiko ist?
Wogegen wollte er euch schützen?
Genau, was ist das, wovor ihr Angst habt? Und dann haben sie meistens so eine Art, wenn sie so irgendwie fünf Minuten drüber nachgedacht haben, wollen sie sich selber schützen. Also stellen sich den Angriff vor, der für das Unternehmen der gefährlichste wäre.
Also nicht für die Kunden, sondern für das Unternehmen.
Für die Kunden, da denken sie meistens sogar noch mit dran. Also ist irgendwie klar, wenn unsere Kunden irgendwie unter die Räder kommen, dann ist das auch für uns schlecht, weil dann stehen wir in den Nachrichten. Aber worüber sie sich meistens weniger Gedanken machen, ist, welche Motivation verfolgt einen Angreifer. Also gibt es da draußen jemanden, der unsere Kundendaten haben möchte oder möchte der vielleicht irgendwas ganz anderes von dem haben, was wir hier betreiben, möchte der zum Beispiel, wenn wir ein Mobilfunknetz betreiben, möchte der Angreifer vielleicht nicht unsere Kundendaten, sondern vielleicht lieber umsonst telefonieren und daraus ein Geschäftsmodell machen. Also es fehlt häufig die Perspektive darüber, mit so einem leichten kriminellen Mindset zu überlegen, so okay, wie kann ich mich an dem, was ihr da habt, bereichern? Worüber habe ich ein Geschäftsmodell? Sind es die Nutzerdaten, ist es irgendwie das Abhören von irgendwas? Was kann ein Angreifer wirklich zu Geld machen? Weil der Angreifer ja auch Zeit und Ressourcen investieren muss. Und das macht er ja in wenigen Fällen einfach so. Ich meine, die Leute gibt es auch.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Aber gegen die wärst du dich eben auch eher mit Standardmaßnahmen. Okay.
Jetzt, wo du gerade schon das alles erzählt hast, sag doch mal kurz, wie du zu dem Job gekommen bist, den du machst.
Ich würde lieber erst noch kurz ein bisschen weiter über den Job reden, weil ich gerade so schön damit angefangen habe. Dann komme ich irgendwann dazu, wie ich dazu gekommen bin. Also du gehst quasi hin und sagst, okay, wovor wollt ihr euch schützen? Weil da geht es ja dann irgendwann los. Dann entwickelst du quasi Szenarien. So was ist das, was der Angreifer möchte? Und dadurch leitest du natürlich auch deinen Penetration-Test. Dadurch wird der geführt. Du pochst jetzt nicht auf irgendwelche Unsicherheiten, die dich nicht am Ende auch zu einem Ziel führen würden, was ein Angreifer verfolgt. Du musst ja irgendwo anfangen. Die Zeilencode sind mehr, als du lesen kannst. Das Programm hat mehr Funktionen, als du alle testen kannst. Also schaust du dir an, wo will ich hin? Was ist das Ziel meines Angriffs? Wie gehe ich da jetzt gezielt dran? Da gehört natürlich dann auch ein Wissen.
Du guckst nicht irgendwie das ganze System einmal komplett durch, sondern du versuchst es quasi von außen anzugreifen.
Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel, eine App, die auf einem Android-Telefon oder so läuft und Kreditkartendaten oder so, dieses Mobile-Payment-Witte ist jetzt gerade modern. Könnte man sich vorstellen, dass das vielleicht einige Unternehmen bauen und dass das einige Unternehmen eventuell sich auch mal gedacht haben, so müsste dann eventuell auch sicher sein. Und dann holen sie sich die Pentester ins Haus. Also dann denkst du dir natürlich als erstes, okay, was sind die Angreifer-Motivationen? Was sind Angreiferszenarien? Ich kann anderen Leuten die Kreditkartendaten klauen. Ich kann versuchen, im Namen anderer Leute Transaktionen durchzuführen. Es gibt also verschiedene Angriffsszenarien, die so ein Produkt erstmal kennzeichnen. Die entwerfen wir dann gemeinsam und dann versuchen wir, die dementsprechend auch uns dem Produkt zu nähern. Also was tut dieses Produkt dagegen?
Wobei man dabei bedenken muss, dass die Angriffsmöglichkeiten nicht zwingend nur eine technische Natur sein können. Gerade in diesem ganzen Bereich, was mit Mobilfunk und Payment zu tun hat, sind sehr viele Angriffe, Kombinationen von organisatorischen und technischen Schwächen. Also zum Beispiel nehmen wir das klassische Beispiel, die SMS-TAN. Also wenn du bei der Bank sagst, ich würde gerne die TAN für meine Transaktion im Online-Banking per SMS bekommen. Da gab es dann allerhand technische Angriffe, mit einem IMSEE-Catcher bauen oder aufs Telefon von dem Angegriffen einen Trojaner aufspielen, um den zu kriegen, dass er diesen Trojaner installiert. Der erfolgreichste Angriff, der mehrere Millionen gebracht hat, war, dass die Leute sich als Händler ausgegeben haben, als Telekom-Händler, und sich für ihre Opfer eine Zweit-SIM-Karte haben ausstellen lassen. Dann haben sie die SMS einfach auf diese Zweit-SIM-Karte bekommen, die sich mit einer Social-Engineering erlangten Händler-Identität haben zuschicken lassen.
Das ist geringsten Widerstand. Die Hackers sind genauso faul. Die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit bei technisch komplizierten Angriffstechniken war zumindest früher auch noch nicht so hoch. Das heißt, der Angriff mit irgendwelchen IMSEE-Catchern und SMS-Lesen über Remote usw. war vor einigen Jahren noch überhaupt nicht denkbar, dass das überhaupt durchführbar ist. Deswegen wurden diese Risiken von den Unternehmen weniger hoch klassifiziert. Die wurden einfach anders gewichtet. Ein paar Jahre später sind IMSEE-Catcher bezahlbar oder diese Protokolle leicht kaputtgegangen. Alle wissen Bescheid, wie man das mit Hausmiteln kompromittieren kann. Und auf einmal ist das große Problem da. Dann kann man sich hinstellen, told you so. Aber man kann genauso gut mit den Unternehmen zusammen Lösungen ausarbeiten, wie sie damit umgehen. M-TAN ist einfach überhaupt nicht geeignet mehr.
Genau. M-TAN ist auf mehreren Ebenen kaputt. Das muss man verstehen. Es gibt technische Angriffswege. Aufs Telefon, auf die Verbindung zum Telefon. Aber auch organisatorisch, wenn man sich die Identität des Angreifers mithilfe von einem Brief und zwei Telefonaten irgendwie aneignen kann, dann hat man halt auch verloren.
Aber ist das sozusagen wirklich, sich das auszudenken, also auch die nicht technischen Angriffslinien, ist das auch deine Aufgabe Linus?
Ja, natürlich. Also alles, im Prinzip alle Annahmen und natürlich anzufangen bei dem Weg des geringsten Widerstandes und sich dann hochzuarbeiten. Häufig kommt man von der Zeitbeschränkung gar nicht über diesen Weg des geringsten Widerstandes hinaus, weil da schon die Liste zu machen ist.
Ja, nur eine ganz lustige Anekdote noch zu diesen SMS-Geschichten. Es gibt ja auch so diese geizige Sky-Mentalität bei den Firmen, die dann darauf reingefallen sind, dass Händler ihnen sehr günstig diesen Versand der SMS für die M-Tanz verkauft haben und die wurden dann über das von Privatkunden aufgekaufte SMS-Budget von Privat-Handys verschickt. Und das hat dann auch jemand rausgefunden, dass da so komische Tanz dann von Privat-Handys verschickt wurden. Also auch da hast du eine wunderbare Angriffsmethode gegen Firmen, weil sie halt auch kein Geld ausgeben wollen.
Ja, wenn sie sparen wollen, haben sie eigentlich schon fast immer verloren.
Also gerade in diesem Sicherheitsbereich. Aber das finde ich auch schon sagen, das ist eine schöne Sache, die man heute gelernt hat, dass quasi IT-Sicherheit für Leute, die nur das BWL im Auge haben, erstmal keinen Gewinn bringt. Also eine IT-Abteilung in einer Firma macht keinen Gewinn, sondern verhindert nur Verluste, das kann man auch gleich darstellen. Linus, du musst aber noch erzählen, wie man überhaupt dazu kommt, dass man einen Job kriegt, wo man sich ausdenkt, wie man möglichst geringen Widerstandssysteme kaputt macht oder ausnutzen kann.
Ich bin da einfach irgendwie drangekommen. Ich habe eigentlich Psychologie studiert.
Das macht fast schon wieder Sinn.
Also ich habe mich irgendwie immer ein bisschen damit auseinandergesetzt, so Sicherheitssysteme auszutricksen oder dann zu überlegen, wie ich selber welche baue, die ich nicht mehr überwinden kann. Und das ist ja auch eine interessante Problemstellung, die nie wirklich zum Ende kommt. Also das absolut sichere System gibt es irgendwie nicht. Und so hat man da immer was Interessantes dran rumzuknobeln und kann irgendwie Sachen besser machen und denkt sich dann so, ah, vielleicht kann ich das ja noch die Weise angreifen. Und es ist einfach eine interessante Aufgabe, die nicht langweilig wird. Und deswegen hat die mich irgendwie, ich glaube seit ich meinen ersten PC hatte, irgendwie begleitet.
Aber Zebas kann ja vorzeigen, also ich weiß hier ISO 27001, ich habe das Zertifikat. Und kann deswegen auch sagen, deswegen müsst ihr mich anstellen. Wie ist das bei dir?
Ich habe kein einziges Zertifikat, kein gar nichts. Wir haben abgeschlossen das Studium als Psychologe und das war's.
Und wie bist du an deinen Job gekommen?
Hab mich beworben und wurde genommen.
Okay, die haben, ja, aber was, was, was, was, was? Also die müssen ja schon aufgrund von irgendwas auch eingestellt haben.
Ja, also ich hab einen schwarzen Hoodie an, sage ich vieles.
Zum Vorstellungsgespräch Ski-Maske nicht vergessen.
Also viele Leute, denen der IT-Sicherheit arbeiten, haben sich eben, sage ich mal, außerhalb eines Informatikstudiums und klassischer zertifizierbarer beruflicher Laufbahn durchaus mit IT-Sicherheit auseinandergesetzt. Und da das eine oder andere Wissen vielleicht auf unkonventionellen Wege erlangt.
Also der Klassiker ist tatsächlich nicht, dass du das im Studium lernst, sondern dass du dir das selber beibringst. Also tatsächlich ist die Grundvoraussetzung einfach eine unbändige Neugier und der Wille, Zeit in das Verständnis von Technologie reinzustecken. Ich sage halt immer so zu Leuten, die sich bei uns bewerben, die nur rein Informatik studiert haben und sonst nichts weiter getan haben. Versuch lieber einfach Dinge zu machen, die ein bisschen unkonventionell sind. Versuch halt irgendwie dieses Thema zu verstehen und selber zu programmieren, die jetzt über das hinausgehen, was du im Studium gelernt hast. Und wie ein Hacker zu denken, erfordert halt eben auch das Interesse zu haben und es nicht nur zu machen, weil man halt irgendwie gerade eine geile Karriere widdert. Also wenn du halt da so anfängst mit irgendwie so ein, naja, was denn der Teil von Informatik, wo man am meisten verdienen kann, so eine Java-Enterprise, vielleicht nicht mehr so werde ich doch Hacker. Das funktioniert so nicht. Also du solltest halt schon irgendwie ein tiefgehendes Interesse dafür haben und einen gewissen Drive haben.
Man muss auch sagen, dass an den Universitäten mittlerweile sehr wohl sehr gute Security-Vorlesungen und Seminare angeboten werden, was sicherlich hilft, wenn man eben diese grundsätzliche Neugierheit auch mitbringt. Also das ist eben das, was man an der Universität nicht lernt.
Also ich vermute oder das war bei uns im Unternehmen so, dass die Strategie bei den Bewerbungsgesprächen ist, oder die ist eigentlich ein Fachgespräch zu führen. Also ich führe bei uns immer so die, machst du die erste Hürde in den Vorstellungsgesprächen und in der Regel denke ich mir dann irgendein Problem aus und versuche mit dem Kandidaten oder mit der Kandidatin einfach darüber zu sprechen. Worüber denkst du dir jetzt nach? Was ist der naheliegendste Angriff? Wo kümmerst du dich als erstes drum? Wie geht es dann weiter? Wo geben wir unser Geld aus, um zu schauen, dass wir es sicher machen können? Weil das Entscheidende bei dieser Tätigkeit, was man auch immer so oft genug in Erinnerung rufen muss, ist, wir sind ja nicht nur da bei den Unternehmen, um unseren eigenen Spaß zu haben und zu sagen, guck mal, hier habe ich gehackt, wuppdi du, jetzt gehe ich zum nächsten. Sondern das Unternehmen hat ja erst was davon, wenn du sagst, ok und jetzt haben wir wirklich was geschaffen oder eine Änderung vorgenommen, die dieses Produkt jetzt wirklich sicherer gemacht hat. Erst dann haben sie ja wirklich was von ihrem Geld. Und das ist also quasi so dieses Hin und Her reden, das kriegt man eigentlich relativ schnell raus, ob da eine Person ist, die dieses Mindset hat oder eben nicht. Man hat häufiger Leute, die halt, also gibt es dann irgendwie so auch manchmal in so einem Extrem, dass die Leute halt nicht Risiken abzuwägen wissen. Irgendwie sagen, es muss alles sicher sein, es muss alles sicher sein. Da kommt es in dem Job halt auch nicht weit mit. Man muss halt irgendwie so überlegen, was sind, wovor habe ich Sorge, was sind die Probleme, die ich habe und ob dann jetzt irgendwie alles verschlüsselt ist oder nicht. Das dann eben irgendwann sprengt dann wirklich halt auch den Rahmen. Also zu überlegen, was mache ich hier mit begrenzten Ressourcen, was ist das, wovor ich mich schützen will und darüber so ein bisschen nachzudenken, das kriegt man relativ schnell raus.
Man muss auch anfangen, pragmatisch zu werden.
Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig in der Branche und das fehlt halt bei vielen, wenn man verschiedene Risiken gleich einfach von vornherein gleich gewichtet. Und da ist halt auch die Kunst drin zu sehen, wie muss ich gewisse Risiken ganz einfach klassifizieren und eben auch entsprechend mit Budget behandeln, um das Thema zu treiben und die größten Schwachstellen erstmal zu beseitigen.
Also bei größten Schwachstellen eigentlich immer heißt geringster Aufwand für den Angreifer größtmöglicher Gewinn für den Angreifer. Also du musst halt beim Denken wie ein Angreifer erstmal primär, entweder wie ein Geheimdienstlicher oder wie ein krimineller Angreifer, daran denken, wie kommt er am einfachsten zu seinem Ziel. Und die Lücken machst du als erstes zu.
Nicht Gewinn für den Angreifer, sondern Schaden für das Unternehmen.
Vom Angreifer ist ja sozusagen erstmal primär, entweder ist das Information oder hinter Geld her. Manchmal gibt es auch Leute, die nur einen Reputationsschaden für das Unternehmen erzeugen wollen. Aber am Ende ist ja dann...
Das wird dir am meisten zeigen.
Ja gut, ja, je nachdem, wenn es bekannt wird oder nicht. Aber wenn du halt als Unternehmen jetzt nur daran denkst, was könnte dir dann am meisten schaden, übersiehst du halt möglicherweise den Angriff, den du vielleicht als gar nicht so schädlich ansiehst, der aber für einen Angreifer extrem attraktiv ist. Also gerade im Telekommunikationsbereich, wo es halt irgendwie diese Premium- und Mehrwertdienste gibt. Naja, der Schaden ist aus der Perspektive von so einer Telco, halt keine Ahnung, vielleicht so 20, 30 Millionen im Jahr ist noch zu verschmerzen. Aber aus der Sicht von Kunden, die dann halt nicht auf der Rechnung haben, zum Beispiel, weil es halt falsch gebucht ist, ist es natürlich extrem bitter. Und da entsteht dann halt eben wiederum der Reputationsschaden.
Aber da möchte ich noch mal fragen, ob es trotzdem diese Mentalität gibt. Also weil es ist ja glaube ich im Bankbereich so, dass die irgendwie so EC-Karten und Credit-Karten, das ist ja nicht sicher und das weiß man und man...
Also je größer das Unternehmen ist, desto stärker ist die Risikoabwägung. Also es wird, also je größer so ein Unternehmen, was den Umsatz ist, angeht, desto mehr sagen die, ok, wenn ich jetzt 7 Millionen ausgeben muss, um dieses Problem zu lösen, mein Schaden ist aber eigentlich nur so 1 bis 2 Millionen pro Jahr, dann kann ich es noch 2, 3 Jahre liegen lassen und mache es halt erst über nächstes Jahr.
Guckt Falk Club.
Geht sogar noch ein bisschen, das geht sogar eigentlich noch weiter. Teilweise werden Systeme absichtlich erst mal technisch unsicher gehalten, weil man dadurch einen anderen Vorteil erlangt. Also ein Beispiel dafür sind zum Beispiel...
Internet of Things.
Internet of Things, ok, we started. Nehmen wir mal was noch kritischeres. Kreditkarten in den USA waren bis vor 2 Jahren ungefähr nur mit Magnetstreifen. Magnetstreifen kannst du einfach auslesen und kopieren. Also diese Dinger hatten einfach keinen Kopierschutz. Und die wurden am laufenden Band missbraucht. Und die Kreditkartenunternehmen haben sich einfach gesagt, ok, wunderbar. Wir schauen uns einfach die ganzen Buchungen an und gucken nach untypischen Mustern. Schauen zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, wenn ich irgendwie... Heute um 18 Uhr bei mir nebenan, wo ich jeden Montagabend tanke, tanken war, dann war ich wahrscheinlich nicht drei Stunden vorher in dem rumänischen Nachtclub und hab da 10.000 Euro umgesetzt. Und machen also quasi einfach Plausibilitätsanalysen auf das Verhalten ihrer Kunden. Und sagen, ok, wir haben ein völlig unzulängliches technisches System, was uns jedes Jahr irgendwie sogar ein paar Milliarden oder eine Milliarde Fraud einfährt. Wir verdienen aber hunderte Milliarden. Und deswegen sagen wir, dieses Prozent Fraud, das können wir uns leisten. Und das nehmen wir als technische Einstiegshürde für jeden anderen, also als finanzielle Einstiegshürde für jeden anderen, der uns Konkurrenz machen möchte. Weil so ein unsicheres System quasi betreiben zu können, ohne dass es ihm vollständig um die Ohren fliegt, muss sich erstmal jemand leisten können. Und jedes sicherere System geht in der Regel mit komplexeren Problemen oder komplexer Anwendungen für den Kunden einher. Oder mit größeren Investitionen in Lesegeräte. Und das haben die jahrzehntelang glücklich gemacht.
Also diese Risikoabwägung, wie es so schön heißt, ist eben auch einer der Teile, die die Leute dann irgendwann dazu bringt zu sagen, ich will doch lieber was mit Holz oder Architekten machen.
Guckt Fight Club.
Weil wenn man sich diese, wenn man das zu häufig und oft genug gesehen hat, wie zynisch dann da teilweise entschieden wird, also wie krass diese Abwägungen sind, dann hat man da irgendwann auch nicht mehr so richtig viel Lust drauf. Also gerade halt in der strategischen IT-Security-Beratung wird das dann halt auch schnell ganz schön doll eklig. Also wenn die Leute halt anfangen, ihre Risikoabwägungen dann halt auch offen darzulegen. Und zu sagen, so Unternehmen vergleichbare Größe haben, als sie neulich gehackt wurden, irgendwie nur einen Aktienkursverfall von 0, 5 Prozent über zwei Wochen gehabt. Wenn uns jetzt hier unsere 30 Millionen Kreditkarten-Kundendaten verloren gehen, heißt das, es kostet uns maximal 500 Millionen, Aktienkurs und vielleicht noch ein bisschen hier und da Kosten. Das ist also ein Risiko, das wir eingehen können. Hingegen, wenn wir unser System komplett umstellen würden, würde uns halt drei Milliarden kosten. Aha, das können wir uns gerade nicht leisten.
Ich möchte diese Sendung niemals gemacht haben. Das ist wieder eine von den Dingen, wo man rausgeht und denkt, ich hätte es über die Welt nicht wissen wollen. Ich möchte aber jetzt noch mal zu THS kommen, weil der sozusagen auch heute ein bisschen dafür zuständig ist, das zu machen, was das Klischee-Bild ist. Wie hast du es vorhin gesagt, tiefer in dieses Thema hineinzugehen? Also tatsächlich mit dem Zerforschen das zu machen. Oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Nein, nein, nein. Das ist halt auch etwas, was in meinen Tätigkeitsbereich fällt. Also unter anderem aber eben auch hauptsächlich so tiefgehende technische Analysen. Das stimmt schon.
Genau, also auch an dich die Frage, wie bist du da hingekommen und wie sieht das konkret aus? Also erst mal dieses, wie bist du da hingekommen? Und wie kommt man dazu, dass man auf einmal auf einmal arbeitet, hier ich mache Dinge kaputt?
Ich hatte einfach Lust darauf und habe das dann gemacht. Das kann man so ganz kurz sagen.
Hast du auch Linus irgendwie Orchideenblütenwissenschaften studiert und hast dann angefangen?
Das ist ja wohl hier ein Informatiker, der nicht programmieren kann oder was?
Nein, nein, ich habe ich habe einen völlig geraden Lebenslauf. Ich bin Heizungsbauer, habe dann Abitur an der Schule für Erwachsenenbildung abgebrochen. Und bin als Quereinsteiger in die Systemadministration gegangen.
Und hast da sozusagen auch Bock drauf gehabt, das andere zu machen?
Genau, da hatte ich dann eigentlich mehr Lust darauf, irgendwie zu verstehen, was die Computer machen. Und mehr Lust den Computern zu sagen, was sie machen sollen. Und dazu fielten mir halt diverse theoretische Hintergründe, weswegen ich danach dann noch ein Studium der Informatik abgebrochen habe und dann technischer Leiter bei der Hacker-Abteilung beim TÜV Rheinland geworden.
Warte, wie ist das passiert?
Was?
Das mit dem TÜV Rheinland?
Nein, das war dann halt eher so, jetzt werde ich halt fürs Hacken auch bezahlt. Das war auch ungefähr in dem Zeitraum.
Ja, aber wie bist du, also ich meine, du bist Hacker, hast du gesagt, hallo, ich bin Heizungsbauer mit abgebrochenen Informatikstudien. Bitte stellt mich ein als technischen Leiter.
Nein, ich habe einfach ein Hobby zum Beruf machen wollen und ich hatte da halt den Einstieg bekommen, weil ich halt schon ein bisschen als Freelancer gearbeitet habe während des Studiums und halt auch Kontakt zu Leuten bekommen habe und dort so nach und nach halt auch mir einen Namen machen konnte durch halt meine Sachen, die ich halt so gemacht habe.
Okay, also du hattest quasi ein Portfolio, was du vorzeigen konntest.
Ja, es war jetzt sehr klein, aber ich hatte halt das Glück und war halt einfach auch neugierig genug und ja, es hat mich halt einfach wahnsinnig interessiert und das ist eben was, was man an der Universität nicht lernt, eben diese Neugier und so weiter, die wird einem nicht beigebracht und ich hab mich ja irgendwie nicht dazu entschieden, irgendwie so einen Job, so einen Weg einzuschlagen, um damit jetzt irgendwie reich zu werden, sondern einfach, weil es mir Spaß macht und Abwechslung bringt, unter anderem. Also das ist eigentlich so die Hauptmotivation von mir. Naja und dann geht es halt so weiter. Ich hab über diesen Werdegang ja eigentlich auch schon mal gesprochen in einem Chaosradio vor ziemlich genau zehn Jahren, wo es auch um das Thema Hacken als Beruf ging. Da war ich im Chaosradio 102, wo wir über diese Thematik schon mal gesprochen haben. Da war ich allerdings tatsächlich auch noch mehr technisch unterwegs und heute eigentlich doch auch ziemlich so, wie Linus seine Tätigkeit beschreibt. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt nicht nur die Leute, die Sachen kaputt machen und den Leuten versuchen, Linux aufzuquatschen. Wir unterhalten uns mit den Leuten und sind...
Aber erklär doch bitte trotzdem, ich mein, ich weiß sozusagen, ihr macht alle bitte was anderes, aber ich hättet trotzdem in der Sendung, wie das genau funktioniert. Also wie genau sieht da die Arbeit aus? Was macht man da?
Also du kommst rein.
Und dann hast du erst mal einen schwarzen Hoodie auf.
Oder einen Anzug an.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle Majestics zitieren, manchmal bin ich so müde. Also okay, andere Frage. Warum schleichen Leute, die in der Branche arbeiten, so sehr darum herum, diese Frage zu beantworten? Also was ist das Geheimnis? Welche Frage? Die Frage danach, wie konkret die Arbeit aussieht.
Ich meine, wie die Arbeit aussieht, ist ganz einfach. Du verhandelst mit dem Kunden und der Kunde hat eine klare Vorstellung davon, was er möchte. Also er sagt halt, okay, ich möchte gerne diese App releasen. Nehmen wir mal einfach, du möchtest gerne deine neue Podcast-App releasen. Und du machst dir Sorgen, wir brechen jetzt mal runter, auf was der Mann auf der Straße so denkt. Wir nehmen dich jetzt mal als Mann auf der Straße. Also du möchtest deine neue Markus-Tolle-Podcasts-App releasen.
Und die hat aber eine Payment-Funktion.
Und die hat eine Payment-Funktion. Also in diese App kannst du deine Paypal-Daten, deine Kreditkarten-Daten und deine Bitcoins eingeben. Das heißt, du bewegst da potenziell Millionen jeden Tag. So für deine tollen Podcasts. Dann gehst du halt hin und sagst, okay, vielleicht wär's schon doof, wenn jetzt irgendwie meine Daten da verloren gehen und dann... Moment, dann gehst du zu Leuten wie Linus oder Thorsten. Und du sagst, liebe Leute, ich will diese App releasen und die ist jetzt eigentlich schon fertig, weil ich hab vorher nicht dran gedacht. Das ist der typische Vorgehen. Was können wir denn machen, um es sicherer zu machen? Wenn der Linus oder Thorsten sagen soll, naja, schade, dass du jetzt schon jetzt erst kommst.
Nächste Woche ist Release.
Wie viel willst du denn anlegen? Wie viel willst du denn anlegen? Aber darum geht es mir gerade gar nicht. Weil du den Prozess schon sehr gut erklärt hast.
Wie viel willst du denn anlegen? Ich will eine Woche anlegen.
Nein, mir geht es nicht darum. Mir geht es jetzt nicht darum, wirklich nicht. Ich habe das verstanden.
Jetzt kommt der nächste Schritt, den hab ich dir gerade erklärt. Der nächste Schritt ist, für eine Woche können wir uns deinen Source Code angucken. Das heißt, du gibst uns deinen Source Code. Und wir gucken nach typischen Fehlern, die du in diesem Source Code gemacht hast. Wir gucken, ob du deine Encryption richtig gemacht hast, ob du deine Zertifikate ordentlich importiert hast, ob du Daten von außen reinbekommst, die in der Lage sind, deine App zu poppen. Also dafür zu sorgen, dass Code in der App ausgeführt wird, die halt nicht ausgeführt werden sollte. Wir gucken, ob die Daten auf deinen Servern so abgelegt werden, dass wenn jemand deinen Server hackt, nicht deine Millionen verloren gehen. Das Ganze ist der einfachste Weg. Du guckst halt einfach den Songscore durch.
Und dann gehst du zu dem Studenten, der dir das Ding geschrieben hat und sagst, gib dem Linus mal den Songscore, der guckt da mal drüber. Und dann sagt der, ne, ne. Das ist genau die Debatte, die du nämlich am Anfang immer hast. Dass du sagst, okay, wir haben jetzt was weiß ich, eine Beauftragung über Zeitraum N, Zeitraum X. Und wir wollen dir in diesem Zeitraum natürlich das beste Ergebnis bieten. Also gib mal Quelltext, gib mal Route-Zugang auf die Server, damit wir uns wirklich alles anschauen können. Und dann hast du immer, da kannst du echt die Uhr nachstellen, einen Techniker, der das Ganze gebaut hat, oder der der Administrator ist, oder der Projektleiter von dem Ding ist, und der sagt, ne, ne, ihr seid doch Hacker, dann zeig ich mal, was ihr könnt. Und dann sagst du, okay, können wir auch machen, wir können das auch auf die harte Tour machen. Dann müsst ihr aber den Projektzeitraum irgendwie einfach mal vervierfachen, weil wir dieses ganze Wissen, quasi in so einem Blackbox-Ansatz erst uns sammeln müssen. Und diese Zeit müsst ihr uns dann auch bezahlen. Wir können es aber auch in diesem Whitebox-Ansatz machen, wo wir alle Informationen von euch bekommen. Der Angreifer weiß schon so viel wie ihr und dann können wir euch sehr viel schneller sagen, ok, da mehr machen, da mehr machen, das sein lassen, hier das Protokoll ändern, die Dinge anders schichten und dann noch irgendwie mal so kurz im Quelltext die klassischen Programmierfehler gesucht. Diese Debatte hast du zu Beginn immer.
So und wie gesagt, wir können ja mal den White-Ansatz, also du hast den Sourcecode, das ist halt der einfache, da liest du halt einfach. Du liest den Sourcecode, du guckst dir die Konfiguration an.
Ist das wirklich so, man liest dann quasi einmal das komplette Ding?
Nein, du liest nicht das komplette Ding. Du hast natürlich eine gewisse Erfahrung, da wird es wahrscheinlich schief gehen. Was machen die Leute immer falsch? Sie machen die SSL kaputt.
Du hast halt so einen Instinkt für Dinge. Du siehst vielleicht auch schon tiefhängende Früchte. Und hast halt so ungefähr, wenn man ein paar Jahre in dieser Branche verbracht hat, dann weiß man halt auch, was sind denn so die klassischen Fehler? Je nach Anwendungsfall, da findet man dann halt schon immer sehr klassische Beispiele.
Also oft gehst du einfach hin und denkst dir, okay, wenn ich das Ding gebaut hätte, wenn ich diese App gemacht hätte, wo sind da die schwierigen Sachen?
Oh, ihr habt eure Krypto selber gemacht.
Danke. Wo werden Protokolle gesprochen, die nicht besonders einfach sind? Wo sind einfach komplexe... Wo wird das Programm so komplex, dass da ein Zweifelsfeindfehler ist?
Wo kommen Daten von draußen rein? Der Klassiker, wenn du einen Angriff, insbesondere gegen Applikationen oder Server fährst, guckst du dir an, wo du eine Möglichkeit hast, das System von außen zu beeinflussen. Das heißt, dass du Daten hineinbekommst.
Aber das ist der Punkt, du kriegst den Zugriff aufs System.
Nee, das machst du auch ohne Zugriff.
Ich meine nicht Zugriff, sondern du kriegst alle Informationen, die die Macher des Systems auch zur Verfügung haben.
Aber dieselbe Logik wendest du auch an, wenn du die Informationen nicht hast. Dann gehst du hin und versuchst, welche Software-Versionen wirst du ein, was für ein Betriebssystem verwendet, welche Tools haben sie benutzt, um es zu entwickeln. Du kannst ja eine Menge Dinge von außen von so einem System sehen, in dem du einfach mit ihm sprichst. Du versuchst halt, irgendwie rauszukriegen.
Okay, warte, darüber reden wir dann gleich.
Jetzt erst mal der Werbeblock.
Genau, eine Pause haben wir heute mal ausgelassen, weil wir aus dem Club sind. Eine machen wir aber. Es gibt eine kleine Musik, das war Mainland von Quaidu Noise. Danach gibt es den NerdNews, gesprochen heute von Christina, geschrieben von Danimo. Und danach geht es hier weiter.
Die Nerd News Wer erpresst wird, sollte nicht zahlen. Diese Binsenweisheit scheint das FBI jetzt zumindest in bestimmten Fällen zu revidieren. Denn wer sich einen Trojaner einfängt, der die Festplatte verschlüsselt und zur Freigabe der Daten ein Lösegeld fordert, bleibt laut Joseph Bonavolonta vom FBI oft nichts anderes übrig. Zu gut sei die sogenannte Ransomware, wie z.B. Cryptolocker, die meistens über entsprechend präparierte Webseiten oder E-Mail-Anhänge den Weg auf Computer findet. Bonavolonta und seine Kollegen können dabei auf fast 1000 Fälle, die den Behörden binnen 12 Monaten gemeldet wurden, zurückgreifen. Insgesamt wurden die Opfer dabei um 18 Millionen US-Dollar erleichtert. Um ihren Ruf zu wahren, würden die Erpresser die Festplatte in der Tat nach Zahlung des Lösegeldes entschlüsseln. Sicherer und billiger ist aber in jedem Fall ein Backup. Der Kampf um Werbeblocker geht in eine neue Runde. Nachdem Bild.de Browser mit Werbeblockern den Zugang verwehrte, ließen sich die Blockerfirmen nicht lange bitten und entwickelten Gegenmaßnahmen. Darauf hat der Springer Verlag nun reagiert. Der Betreiberfirma von AdBlock Plus hat das Landgericht Hamburg per einstweiliger Verfügung die Verbreitung von Entgehungsregeln verboten. Zusätzlich soll auch jeder abgemahnt werden, der dokumentiert, wie man die AdBlock Blockade loswirkt. Das bekam auch der YouTuber Tobias Richter zu spüren, der auf seinem YouTube-Kanal erklärte, wie einfach sich die Sperre umgehen lässt. Die Anwälte von Bild.de sehen in dieser Anleitung einen Verstoß gegen §95 des Urheberrechtsgesetzes. Dazu müssten die Werbeblocker Blocker aber eine wirksame technische Maßnahme darstellen, was bezweifelt werden darf. Das sieht wohl auch Richter so. Sein Anwalt gab an, dass man weder die geforderte Unterlassungserklärung abgeben, noch die Kosten für die Abmahnung übernehmen werde. Wir drücken die Daumen. Mit exakt 404 Ja-Stimmen hat der Bundestag die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als sogenannte Höchstspeicherfrist wieder eingeführt. Laut Gesetz werden Handy-Standortdaten vier Wochen, Verkehrsdaten wie SMS, Berufnummern und IP-Adresse des Handys sogar zehn Wochen gespeichert. Aus technischen Gründen sind bei SMS auch Inhalte von der Speicherung betroffen. Auch enthält das Gesetz keinerlei Ausnahmeregelung für Berufsgruppen wie Anwälte, Ärzte oder Journalisten, die einem Berufsgeheimnis unterliegen oder Quellenschutz gewähren müssen. Das Gesetz, das mit einem rekordverdächtigen Tempo durch die Instanzen gejagt wurde, schafft außerdem den Straftatbestand der Datenhehlerei. Das könnte für Whistleblower gefährlich werden, die Daten aus ihrem Unternehmen und Behörden an die Öffentlichkeit bringen und Journalisten über diese Daten berichten wollen. Der Verein Digitalcourage und andere haben Klage gegen die neue Auflage der Vorratsdatenspeicherung angekündigt. Auch das EU-Parlament hat im Internet einen Bärendienst erwiesen. Mit dem nun beschlossenen sogenannten Trilogkompromiss zur Netzneutralität steht es den Telekommunikationsunternehmen frei, gewisse Dienste als Spezialdienste zu markieren, die sie auf die Überholspur schicken dürfen. Das hat die Telekom in ihrem Blog dankend aufgenommen. Dort fasst Konzernchef Höttges den Begriff Spezialdienst so weit, dass fast jeder heutige Internetdienst darunter fällt. Walter behauptet eher, dass Spezialdienst die Lösung für Start-ups sei, um Nachteile gegenüber Firmen wie Google, die weltweit Serverpacks besäßen, auszugleichen. Darüber, wie gut das für Google funktioniert, können Telekom Kunden ein Lied singen, während sie auf ihre YouTube Videos warten.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 217, live aus der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin im Chaos Computer Club Berlin mit Linus, Frank, Sebas und TAS. Hallo und guten Abend.
Und wir waren gerade live dabei, Markus tolle Premiere-Podcast abzueanalysieren, um euch zu erklären, wie das eigentlich mit den Marken funktioniert. Das werden wir jetzt mal weitermachen.
Warte, gleich. Ich möchte vorher noch kurz sozusagen, ich möchte noch kurz eine News-Beeldung, die in der Nerd-News auch gerade drin war, aufgreifen. Und zwar, ich hab ja gerade einen schönen Tweet gelesen, die Telekom reagiert mal schnell, dass ich das noch erleben darf. Die haben ja tatsächlich sozusagen einen Tag, nachdem das EU-Parlament gesagt hat, ja, so ein Netzteil da tritt, ist super, wir definieren das mal auf eine Art und Weise, die die aushebelt, gesagt, ja, wir möchten gerne, wie war das, Start-ups?
Sie wollen einfach nur ein paar Prozent von dem schönen Start-up-Umsatz abfangen.
Also was mich daran total fasziniert ist, früher war es ja immer so, die Internet-Anbieter haben gesagt, naja, also die großen Anbieter, die machen uns ja die Leitungen so dick. Wir möchten, dass die sich an unserer Infrastruktur beteiligen. Und das finde ich jetzt so perfide, dass sie sagen, naja, die großen Anbieter haben ihre Server eh in der Nähe. Das können die Kleinen sicher nicht leisten. Dann möchten wir von denen ein paar Prozent, um sie durchzuleiten.
Schönes Start-up haben sie da.
Als fairen Beitrag für die Nutzung der Infrastruktur.
Bei einem von InfoX-Providern in Deutschland musst du ein paar Prozent von deinem Umsatz lassen. Es gibt ja noch den Rest Europas, es gibt noch den Rest der Welt. Und dann gibt es auch noch ein kleines bisschen Restumsatz für dich.
Das ist so perfide und schamlos vor allem.
Ja, das ist schamlos. So sind sie.
Also ich würde mal vermuten, dass sie damit einigermaßen Schiffbruch erleiden. Weil natürlich wird es ein paar Firmen geben, die sich da halt erpressen lassen müssen, weil ihr Geschäftsmodell halt so aussieht. Aber ich erwarte eigentlich eher, dass der Trend dahingeht, dass so eine Firma wie Netflix oder so, die halt irgendwie darauf angewiesen sind, dass ihre Videos ruckelfrei kommen, halt ja das Schutzgeld zahlen und andere halt einfach sich Businesses suchen werden und da Kreativität hin tun werden, wo sie halt keinen breiten Schutzgeld zahlen müssen.
Also was ich mir vorstelle, ich würde ja als User hingehen und sagen, ich möchte bitte bei einem ISP sein, der das nicht macht. Meint ihr, dass das auch als Verkaufskontakt kommen wird?
Also ich meine, wenn du kannst, klar. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich ein, also alle anderen großen ISPs, also nicht alle, aber fast alle anderen großen ISPs sagen ja, wir peeren halt, das heißt, wir schließen uns halt zusammen, wie es in der Tat mal gemeint war. Und nur die Telekom sagt halt, wir sind so groß, wir haben so viele Kunden. Wenn du unsere Kunden schnell erreichen möchtest, musst du Geld dafür bezahlen, dass du dich auch schnell anbinden kannst. Wenn sie sowas mit Google machen, na gut, da kann man drüber reden, oder mit Netflix oder so, das kann man zumindest so inhaltlich nachvollziehen. Aber wenn sie es halt mit so kleinen Audio-Streaming-Startups machen, würde ich sagen, könnte das Kartellamter schon durchaus noch mal ein Wortchen mitzureden haben.
Wäre es nicht gut, wenn sowas wie die Telekom staatliche Infrastruktur wäre?
Also ja klar, ich meine, es ist vollkommen logisch, dass so was wie ein hochbrandbreitiges Netz sollte halt eigentlich eine öffentliche Infrastruktur sein. Also es muss nicht staatlich sein, sondern halt am besten öffentlich. Das heißt, es ist so, dass es halt nicht profitorientiert ist. Und dann, so wie halt im Baltikum, da hat der Staat halt auch einfach Faser in jedes Dorf gelegt und gesagt, alle Firmen, die brandbreiten Dienstanbeit anbieten wollen, können zu den gleichen Konditionen Kapazität auf diesem Netz liegen und damit wird halt dieses Netz ausgebaut. So gehört sich das für natürliches Monopol.
Schön wär's gewesen. Heute machen wir aber bei Chaosradio etwas ganz anderes. Nämlich wir reden über professioneller Hacker. Und haben in der ersten Stunde schon so ein bisschen gelernt, dass da sehr viel theoretische Arbeit auch dabei ist. Und dass man sich auch mit Kundendingen rumschlagen muss. Zum Beispiel sowas wie, naja, das kostet halt schon auch Geld, wenn ihr uns einkauft. Und dann wollen die vielleicht auch das Ergebnis gar nicht so gerne haben. Und es gibt noch die Diskussion, also stellt sozusagen, wenn ich mir jetzt so jemanden angucke, der die Sicherheit meiner Firma oder meines Produktes überprüfen soll, stelle ich dem jetzt mal einen Quellcode zur Verfügung. Das ist der sogenannte Whitebox-Ansatz. Oder sage ich, was sagen die dann immer so? Du bist doch Hacker, zeig mal was du kannst.
Ja, das muss man denen dann am Anfang immer mal kurz erklären, dass man eigentlich da ist, um ihnen zu helfen und nicht, um irgendjemanden bloßzustellen. Aber die Angst ist natürlich am Anfang da.
Das mit dem Bloßstellen ist wirklich ein großes Problem. Viele, die unerfahren sind mit solchen Untersuchungen in den eigenen Firmen, die denken wirklich, dass da jemand an den Pranger gestellt wird für irgendetwas, was passiert.
Also warte mal, ist die Erwartung von den Leuten, die dieses Thema bauen, ist quasi, sie dürfen eigentlich keine Fehler machen. Und es ist nicht verinnerlich, dass es eigentlich der natürliche Gang ist, wenn du eine Software baust, dann hat die auch eine Schwachstelle.
Ich würde das jetzt mal vorsichtig sagen, das ist ja eher ein Problem der Kultur des Unternehmens, wenn die Mitarbeiter irgendwie Probleme befürchten, wenn das Unternehmen ihnen Leute zur Seite stellt, die teuer bezahlt werden, um ihnen zu helfen bei ihrem Produkt. Deswegen ist da so ein Psychologiestudium gar nicht so schlecht, da irgendwie auch zu sehen, wie kriege ich denn die Person jetzt mit an Bord? Wie nehme ich denen auch ihre Sorge? Also es ist mir jetzt wirklich noch nie untergekommen, dass irgendjemand von denen, sind ja dann auch nicht immer nur angestelltes Unternehmen, es sind häufig auch Zulieferer. Dann hast du halt so einen richtig schönen Clusterfuck, weil dann der, was weiß ich, das Unternehmen hat die App jetzt von irgendeinem anderen Unternehmen gekauft und dieses andere Unternehmen sagt dann aber, nee, also in unserem Service-Level-Agreement steht drin, ihr kriegt keinen Einweg in den Source Code oder so, oder ihr dürft das gar nicht prüfen lassen, dann streiten die sich da erst mal. Und das sind halt die dümmsten Zulieferer, weil das Unternehmen an das du verkaufst spendiert dir noch einen Pentest.
Also nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel deine Podcast-App, du hast jetzt einen Studentenbeauftragten, also wir wollen konkret bleiben, du hast da so einen Studentenbeauftragten, der hat dir die geschrieben und dann fällt dir plötzlich ein, weil du halt so Leute wie uns kennst, irgendwie dass du dir ja vielleicht doch mal eine Sicherheitsanalyse machen lassen. Dann gehst du zu deinem Studenten und sagst dem, ich würde ja doch gerne mal an die Sicherheit reingucken lassen. Und dann sagt der Student so, weißt du in der Macke, bei mir ist alles sicher. So und natürlich rücke ich den Sourcecode nicht raus, weil das wäre mein Lebensunterhalt. Und dann sagst du aber, ich würde trotzdem die Sicherheit gerne prüfen lassen. Dann sagt der, mach was du willst, aber nicht mit meinem Sourcecode. Und dann gehst du halt zu Thorsten zum Beispiel und sagst, pass auf, der gibt mir den Sourcecode nicht, kannst du trotzdem mal reingucken. Und dann findet Thorsten da halt irgendwie eine Tonne Zeug drin. Und dann gehst du zurück zu ihm und sagst so, Alter, ey, das ist nur für einen Scheiß hier abgeliefert. So irgendwie, da sind 15 Sicherheitslücken drin. Ich will, dass du die mal fixen, und zwar für lau, weil du hast ja gesagt, bei dir ist alles sicher. Das ist so ein typischer Ablauf eines solchen Einkaufsdialoges. Und unter Involvierung eines Sicherheitslückens.
Aber wie findet Thorsten die 15 Sicherheitslücken?
Da waren wir ja gerade. Also wir nehmen mal halt an, also der gibt dir den Sourcecode nicht, sondern wir müssen es halt Blackbox machen. Dann fängt man halt an, sich die einzelnen Komponenten anzugucken. Also was haben wir denn da so? Also da gibt es halt zum einen ein Payment, also da wo halt irgendwie dein Geld fließt. Da würde man, wenn man jetzt sagt, du hast nur eine Woche am meisten Zeit wahrscheinlich verbringen. Das heißt, wir gucken uns halt an, wie wird, wenn die Kreditkartendaten von deiner App zu deinem Server gebracht, wie wird auf deinem Server die Verbindung zum Kreditkartendienstleister hergestellt? Verwendest du da richtige Verschlüsselungen? Reicherst du die Daten?
Ich würde es aber erst endlich noch eine Runde genauer wissen. Wie machst du das?
Man muss sich dann schon genau angucken, was ist das für eine App, wie kommuniziert die, wo läuft die drauf. Da muss man einfach nur ein paar mehr Hürden nehmen. Wenn irgendwelche Programmierer den Code oder die Apps nicht rausrücken, dann heißt das ja nicht, dass man da nicht rankommt. Man hat einfach ein paar mehr Hürden zu nehmen. Manchmal ist es komplizierter und manchmal nicht. Ich habe tatsächlich gerade genau so einen Fall, wo ein Kunde mich damit beauftragt hat, etwas mit so einer Anwendung zu tun und zu analysieren. Der hat von seinem Drittanbieter noch nicht mal das Package bekommen, was auf den Geräten deploit wird, geschweige denn den Source Code. Dann muss man einfach versuchen, erst mal zu schauen, wie kommuniziert die App. Dann kann man den Netzwerkverkehr analysieren. Daran kann man schon mal eine ganze Menge sehen. Man kann gucken, ob die Krypto sauber ist und so weiter. Dann kann man an anderen Punkten ansetzen, an die Anwendung zu gelangen. Zum Beispiel auf einem Telefon. Da gibt es häufig auch noch andere Vektoren, die man nutzen kann. So ein Android-Telefon kann man dann routen. Dann hast du schon mal Zugriff auf die Daten auf dem Device, was auf dem Dateisystem liegt. Dann kann man da schon mal schauen, was für Daten werden von der Anwendung auf der Festplatte oder auf dem Dateisystem gespeichert. Sind da sensible Daten dabei? Vielleicht sogar Passwörter oder irgendwelche kryptographischen Schlüssel, die dann da abgelegt werden. Dann kann man die nutzen und vielleicht sogar versuchen, einen eigenen Client zu bauen, der dann später mit einem Backend kommuniziert und auch verschlüsselt kommuniziert. Und dann geht man halt so Stück für Stück, arbeitet man sich dann da halt so durch. Das ist teilweise mühsam, teilweise geht es auch ganz schnell. Und auch da geht man ja oft den Weg des geringsten Widerstands. Das heißt so, am erst guckt man sich so äußerlich ein bisschen an, was passiert da. Und zusätzlich eher dann, ja, wenn man eben nichts anderes mehr findet oder so, dann kann man halt immer noch auch die Applikationen zum Beispiel in den Disassembler werfen und sich den Code angucken und versuchen herauszufinden, was die Anwendung am Ende tut, wie Daten von A nach B fließen innerhalb der Anwendung, wo vielleicht irgendwas verschlüsselt wird, ob da irgendwelche logischen Fehler eingebaut sind in der Applikation. Und das ist dann halt so dieser klassische Blackbox-Ansatz. Man muss halt einfach eine Hürde nach der anderen nehmen und das ist einfach mühsam und sehr zeitaufwendig. Und würde ich auch niemandem empfehlen, das so auf die Art und Weise durchzuführen. Weil am Ende wird das halt immer irgendwie einen Weg geben, an irgendwelche Geheimnisse zu gelangen. Und es ist ja jetzt auch kein Geheimnis, dass man eher auf Geheimnisse... Also, dass man auch solche... Man soll halt nicht dafür sorgen, dass der Algorithmus geheim gehalten wird, sondern eben andere Dinge. Das heißt, das Kerkovsche Prinzip wird halt oft genug verletzt und die Programmierer sollten halt einfach davon absehen, diese Denkweise weiterzuführen. Sie sollten eher davon ausgehen, dass grundsätzlich sowieso jeder Zugriff hat auf die Anwendung und vielleicht sogar auf den Source-Code. Das kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass der Arbeitsrechner von dem Programmierer bereits kompromittiert ist und der Source-Code schon in irgendwelchen Foren die Runde macht. Das kann ja halt auch durchaus möglich sein. Und dann ist es eben einfacher für Consultants wie uns einfach schnell mal in diesen Code rein zu gucken und eben sehr viel schneller und gezielter nach den klassischen Programmierfehlern zu suchen.
Aber wenn du diesen Blackbox-Ansatz machst und dann diese Hürden nehmen musst, ist das dann jedes Mal von vorne? Oder gibt es da auch dann irgendwie Werkzeuge dafür? Wie macht man das?
Jaja, da gibt es dann natürlich auch Werkzeuge. Zum einen eben so allgemeine Werkzeuge, die es auf jeder Linux-Distribution gibt und auch sonst wie frei im Internet erhältlich sind. Es gibt ja schon seit sehr langer Zeit solche Linux-Distributionen wie Backtrack oder Kali Linux, die im Grunde auch nur so ein Werkzeugkoffer sind mit Open Source Tools oder irgendwelchen Werkzeugen, die mal von Hackern und Sicherheitsforschern entwickelt wurden, um die Analysearbeiten zu erleichtern. Oder eben auch eigene Werkzeuge, die man dann am Ende vielleicht nicht releast, weil es halt eben einfach Ergebnisse aus jahrelanger Spezialisierung sind, die man halt durchgemacht hat. Also wenn ich jetzt zehn Jahre in der Branche arbeite und mich auf bestimmte Plattformen oder Anwendungen spezialisiert habe, dann habe ich ja im Laufe der Zeit auch Anwendungen oder Programme zur Analyse entwickelt, die ich jetzt nicht jedem Preis gebe, weil das macht ja vielleicht auch irgendwie meinen Wert auf diesem Security-Markt aus, wenn ich eben Werkzeuge habe, die mich sehr viel effizienter arbeiten lassen.
Aber kommt man da nicht auch in eine moralische Zwickmühle? Will man so eine Werkzeuge, also aus der idealistischen Perspektive nicht, dass die möglichst jeder in der Hand hat, damit möglichst jeder möglichst gut testen kann?
Natürlich, aber ich denke da wiegt man halt auch ab. Also es gibt durchaus Werkzeuge und Algorithmen, die man halt releasen sollte, damit alle was davon haben. Aber ich meine jetzt nicht so einzelne Geschichten, so was ich, wenn ich eine Sicherheitslücke in irgendeiner Software finde, die frei verkauft wird oder die irgendwie Open Source ist, dann behalte ich diese Sicherheitslücke nicht für mich und ich werde auch keinen Exploit dafür bauen, also irgendwie ein Stück Programm, was diese Sicherheitslücke ausnutzt und das Ganze für mich behalten. Das sind dann eher Sachen, die man dann veröffentlichen sollte, damit die Hersteller der Software auch ein bisschen unter Druck gesetzt sind, diese Probleme schnell zu beheben, damit eben die anderen, die diese Software nutzen, nicht mehr gefährdet sind.
Wie wichtig ist es in so einem Fall eigentlich, dass ihr Software benutzt, die wiederum andere geschrieben haben? Weil es gibt ja irgendwie so Schad-Baukästen, also z.B. hat jemand gefragt, Metasploit ist wohl einer oder Open-Was? Also das sind ja so Baukäste für Schad-Software.
Also Metasploit finde ich jetzt überhaupt nicht, fällt gar nicht so in die Kategorie.
Kannst du kurz erklären, was das ist, bevor du sagst, warum es nicht in die Kategorie fällt?
Ja, Metasploit würde ich gerade sagen. Das ist eher so ein Framework, wo sich halt irgendwie mal Leute hingesetzt haben und gesagt haben, wir bauen, wir müssen uns immer in dieser ganzen Security-Branche, sind wir halt immer mit diesen gleichen Problemen konfrontiert. Das, was du ja gerade angesprochen hast, wir müssen immer mal irgendwo einen Portscan machen und immer mal gucken, ob irgendwie, weiß ich, eine Krypto-Implementierung korrekt antwortet auf irgendeinem Server und so weiter. Das sind halt so diese ganzen allgemeinen Tests, die kann man ja automatisiert durchführen und dafür kann man halt Scanner bauen. Und dann gibt es halt eben diese Exploits, also um halt irgendwie auch beweisen zu können, dass eine Sicherheitslücke in einer Software ausnutzbar ist, kann man dann halt Exploits bauen. Und irgendwann haben sich mal Leute gesagt, wir müssen das immer wieder machen und immer wieder fangen wir so, haben wir den ganzen Overhead, wie jedes Mal so ein Unit-Test irgendwie neu zu bauen. Wir bauen uns jetzt erstmal ein Framework, sodass man, weiß ich mal, so ein Scanner oder irgendein Analysewerkzeug oder irgendein Exploit einfach schnell prototypen kann und in dieses Framework reinwirft. Und das Ganze ist dann wieder im Grunde genommen ein riesengroßer Werkzeugkoffer, nur halt eben sehr speziell für diese ganze Security-Branche. Und das ist wirklich nur ein Framework. Das ist halt so, wie wenn ich mir ein LKW miete und da Regale einbaue, dass da meine Koffer mit den Werkzeugen perfekt reinpassen, damit ich damit zum Kunden fahren kann. Metasploit ist halt kein Baukasten für irgendeine Schadsoftware, sondern einfach nur ein Framework, was es erleichtert, solche Tests zu implementieren. Und natürlich eben auch Exploit, keine Frage, aber deswegen ist es noch lange kein Schadsoftware-Baukasten.
Also worauf du ja hinaus willst, Markus, ist, dass natürlich viele dieser Werkzeuge, wenn sie für Angriffe auf Computersysteme nutzbar sind, unter anderen Bedingungen sicherlich auch für solche Angriffe genutzt werden können. Und grundsätzlich ist ja erstmal die Frage, wenn ich jetzt dahin komme und ich habe die Aufgabe, ein System oder eine App oder sonst was gegen einen zeitgemäßen Angreifer zu verteidigen, dann kann ich mir jetzt nicht irgendwelche esoterischen, religiösen Fesseln anlegen und sagen, ich mach das aber jetzt immer, ich fange jetzt immer mit einem Stock an und baue mir meinen Hammer selber. Wenn ich weiß, folgender Spezialhammer, Presslufthammer ist auf dem Markt erhältlich. Oder Hammer-Podcast-App. Folgende Tools sind leicht erhältlich, folgende Angriffe gibt es. Dann ist es natürlich auch sinnvoll, diese im Rahmen von Tests durchzuführen, zur Anwendung zu bringen. Es bringt ja nichts zu sagen, ich habe jetzt hier den weißen Westepenntest gemacht ohne Angriffe. Du willst ja Angriffe durchführen, also nutzt du natürlich auch Tools, die Angriffe durchführen können. Zum Zwecke oder mit dem Ziel, diese Angriffe abzuwehren.
Genau. Und es gibt halt wirklich viele Kunden, die eben nicht damit einverstanden sind, wenn man einfach nur ein theoretisches Risiko aufzeigt in einem Stück Software. Manche wollen halt wirklich sehen, dass das auch wirklich kaputt geht. Weil auch gerade in größeren Software-Entwicklungsfirmen, die Entwickler stellen sich auch dann oft quer und denken halt so, man fährt ihnen halt irgendwie gegen Karren und die leugnen dann erstmal, dass man da einen Fehler gemacht hat. Und dann ist es halt einfacher auch, dass man dann einfach da hergehen kann und sagen kann, so pass auf, wenn ich hier diesen Knopf drücke, dann bin ich rot auf dieser Kiste da und das sagt halt alles. Ihr könnt jetzt irgendwie diskutieren, so lange wie ihr wollt. Das ist eigentlich auch egal, wer Schuld daran hat. Die Sache ist, es funktioniert. Hier ist der Beweis. Und wir müssen diese Sache jetzt fixen. Und jetzt lasst uns eher darüber diskutieren, wie man das fixt und nicht darüber diskutieren, wie wir das mit der Schuldzuweisung klären. Also das ist eben so eine Diskussion, die man regelmäßig hat.
Klappt dann trotzdem nicht, aber gegenüber Dritten unbeteiligt machst du einen sehr konstruktiven Eindruck.
Aber zu dem Punkt, nochmal zurückzukommen. Man benutzt auch andere Software sozusagen. Die Software, die man, wenn man böse ist, auch direkt so als Schadding ins einen setzen kann.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Kategorien von Software. Man hat zum einen so etwas wie Exploits oder Trojaner, die man dann auf das Zielsystem aufbringt, um zu seinem Ziel zu kommen. Vorher hat man meistens noch ein bisschen mit Reverse-Engineering zu tun. Also, dass man einfach Software auseinandernimmt, dekompiliert, sie wieder lesbar macht, sie in einen Zustand bringt, wo man sie verstehen kann, um die Fehler daran zu finden. Wenn man den Source Code nicht kriegt, nehme ich mir eine App, dekompiliere sie, mache da lesbaren Code für mich draus, um zu verstehen.
Außer bei Oracle, die haben das verboten.
Insiderwitz. Es gibt Firmen, die sagen, du darfst die Software nicht dekompilieren.
Selbst wenn du einen Security-Test machst?
Selbst wenn du einen Security-Test machst. Eigentlich ist es immer Bullshit, in Deutschland darfst du es tun. Es gibt zwei Gründe, wie du das machen kannst. Zum einen, um Kompatibilität mit dieser Software zu stellen, zum anderen, um sie zu überprüfen. Dann darfst du die Software auseinandernehmen und zerlegen. In der Regel, wenn du so etwas im Auftrag machst, dann lässt du dir dieses Einverständnis geben. Häufig ist es gerade so, wenn große Firmen zum Beispiel irgendwelche Apps analysieren lassen, die sie verwenden wollen, was immer häufiger der Fall ist, dann holen sich das Einverständnis von dem Hersteller diese App und sagen, pass auf, wenn wir da nicht reingucken dürfen oder das nicht analysieren lassen dürfen, dann kaufen wir sie halt nicht.
Aber umgekehrt geht auch. Der große Kunde sagt dem Hersteller, wir wollen hier reingucken und der sagt, so habt ihr eine Meise, wenn ihr das macht, zeige ich euch an. Diese Fälle gibt es auch. Die lassen sich tatsächlich auch unter Druck setzen, weil keiner hat dann Bock auf juristische Auseinandersetzung.
Wir haben hier eine Frage aus dem Publikum.
Wenn es so viele Leute gibt, die sich dagegen stellen, woher kommen dann eigentlich die gesamten Aufträge?
Meistens ist es so, dass es in so einem Unternehmen verschiedene Interessen gibt. Es gibt die Leute, die nicht wollen, dass ihr Unternehmen kleinige Schlagzeilen hat. Die sind dann meistens noch die, die man eher dazu überreden kann oder die eher auf die Idee kommen. Dann gibt es Unternehmen, bei denen es mittlerweile eher normal geworden ist. Die sagen, wenn wir eine neue Applikation releasen, dann müssen wir in den Prozess, bis diese Applikation nach draußen kommt, dass dann jemand unterwegs ist, muss eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung rein. Da gibt es Standards, da kannst du vielleicht am besten was zu sagen, wie das so funktioniert mit der Security Compliance.
Ja genau, da die Unternehmen ganz gerne vorher ein mögliches Risiko eingehen wollen, sagt man ganz einfach, wenn man kritischen Pfad in einem Produkt hat, dass der einfach nochmal durchleuchtet wird, bevor man damit wirklich an die Öffentlichkeit geht oder ein Produkt im Livebetrieb einsetzt. Man versucht dann meistens auf die Bereiche zu beschränken, die wirklich auf einem kritischen Pfad sind und erstmal dieses Thema zu bewerten und dann im Nachgang der restlichen Infrastruktur nachzuziehen.
Die Aufträge, am Ende wollen ja schon alle, dass es sicher ist. Und ich glaube, wir haben auch jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr von den alltäglichen Grabenkämpfen da gesprochen. In der Regel schleift sich das im Laufe des Projektes ein. Also Anfangs sagen alle, oh mein Gott, jetzt kommen hier die Hacker rein und so. Und dann muss man einfach nur am Anfang eben ein bisschen freundlich sein, sich allen gegenüber konstruktiv zeigen, dass man das dann auch in der Regel hinkriegt, dass am Ende doch alle an einem Strang ziehen.
Man arbeitet zu Beginn auch so ein Stück weit als Mediator, um zwischen den Fronten zu verhandeln, dass die Leute sich an einen Tisch setzen und man lösungsorientiert arbeitet und nicht problemorientiert.
Aber der Konflikt, den ich eigentlich heutzutage sehe, ist, dass die Unternehmen nämlich wirklich am Ende dann sich erst die Leute holen. Das heißt, sie machen sich lange genug keine Gedanken darüber. Das heißt, diese sichere Entwicklung oder so ist nicht von Anfang an in der Gestaltung des Produktes oder der Dienstleistung mit drin. Das heißt, sie entscheiden sich vielleicht bewusst oder unbewusst dagegen, von Anfang an die Experten mit an Bord zu haben. Und lassen sich dann am Ende lieber einmal alles kaputt hauen und fixen dann die Probleme und sagen, okay, jetzt ist es reif. Ich persönlich würde eigentlich eher den Unternehmen dazu raten, von vornherein Sicherheitserwägungen schon in der Architektur- und Designphase ausreichend zu berücksichtigen.
Also typischerweise kann man sagen, je größer ein Unternehmen ist, und desto häufiger es schon mal irgendwie tatsächlich sich auf die Fresse gepackt hat, weil sie halt Sicherheitsprobleme zu spät eingegangen haben, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass sie halt einen Prozess haben, wenn sie halt eine neue Applikation einführen und ein neues Produkt oder was auch immer oder überhaupt irgendwie an ihre IT rumfummeln, dass es dann halt da irgendwie schon von vornherein so eine strukturelle Beteiligung der Sicherheitsabteilungen gibt und die dann halt irgendwann sagen, okay, wir holen heute von extern dazu. Je kleiner das Unternehmen ist, je mehr ist halt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, so Start-up-Mode ist, je weniger Erfahrung die Leute auch damit haben, sich halt irgendwie als Prozess zu begreifen, desto eher gibt es da halt große Widerstände bzw. halt Unwillen, halt sowas halt von vornherein zu berücksichtigen. Das ist halt so Daumenregel. Es gibt halt natürlich Abweichungen in beide Richtungen. Es gibt auch große Unternehmen, die sind einfach so stulle. Da fragt man sich, wie sie mal zu groß werden konnten. Es gibt kleine Unternehmen, bei denen ist die Security total super, aber das ist halt eher die Ausnahme.
So, ich möchte noch mal zu meiner Frage von vorhin zurückkehren. Ich möchte sie mal ganz konkret stellen. Wer von euch hat schon mal einen Trojaner gekauft für die Arbeit?
Ich.
Warum?
Na, wir machen halt sich halt Mobiltelefone und da gehört unter anderem dazu, dass wir auch gucken, wie funktionieren so eine Trojaner. Wenn man halt sich so einen Trojaner auf dem Telefon einfängt, haben wir Möglichkeiten dafür zu sorgen, dass zumindest die sicheren Telefonate an dem Trojaner vorbeigehen. Wie kann man erkennen, dass ein Trojaner auf dem Telefon drauf ist anhand von verschiedensten Parametern? Und dazu gucken wir uns die natürlich an. Also ganz normaler Arbeitsprozesse gucken wir uns jetzt nicht alle an, aber so die up-to-date zu bleiben, was so die wesentlichen Tricks angeht, tun wir das natürlich schon.
Also genau. Würde ich auch nicht fragen, du hast schon mal einen Trojaner gekauft?
Ich würde die lieber cracken und nicht kaufen.
Aber du hast mal einen Trojaner besorgt? Selbstverständlich natürlich.
Ich hab mir auch schon mal einen Trojaner besorgt. Aber ich bau dann eher mal irgendwie sowas selber, wenn das notwendig ist für solche Sachen.
Wir haben regelmäßig Kunden, die sich welche einkaufen.
Okay, so, jetzt hab ich gehört, dass neulich den Besitz eines Trojaners einer Staatsanwaltschaft ausgereicht hat, um Rechner aus diversen Häusern zu tragen. Frank, du hast das jetzt schon gelaufen.
Genau, also die haben, ich glaube, was war die letzte Zahl? Ich muss noch mal auf Heise gucken, was die... Also ein gutes Dutzend Hausdurchsuchungen durchgeführt um...
13.
Ja, 13, ja. Bei Leuten, wo sie irgendwo hier die Information hatten, dass die einen Android-Trojaner gekauft haben.
Okay, was war der Hintergrund dieses Android-Trojaners?
Paragraph 202c StGB.
Nee, ich meine nicht den russischen Hintergrund, sondern diese Android-Trojaner. Was zu sagen, was ist das für ein Ding?
Also, vielleicht nochmal kurz. Was ist ein Trojaner? Trojaner ist eine Schadsoftware, die auf irgendeinem Gerät läuft und in der Regel halt einen Fernzugriff ermöglicht. Dieser Trojaner muss, um das zu tun, in der Regel mit einem zweiten Rechner sprechen. Nennt man in der Regel Command & Control Server. Das heißt, das ist der Rechner, dem der Trojaner meldet, guck mal hier. Hier wurde gerade eine E-Mail geschrieben. Die hab ich mal abgezweigt. Oder hier ist gerade ein SMS eingegangen. Oder wie du mir befohlen hast, habe ich mal ein Foto gemacht und schicke das zurück. Und wenn man sowas dann irgendwann mal gebaut hat, dann könnte man entweder den Leuten das alles Open Source zur Verfügung stellen und sagen, hier habt ihr einen schönen Demo, Trojaner. Oder man könnte auf die Idee kommen, zu sagen, okay, ich mach daraus ein Geschäftsmodell, dass ich diese App an Menschen verkaufe, die die dann auf natürlich nur ihrem eigenen Telefon zu Testzwecken installieren und mir monatlich einen Betrag dafür bezahlen, dass sie auf meinen Command-and-Control-Server zugreifen können, mit dem ich ja dann die infizierten Geräte ausspioniere und ich ihnen dann Zugriff auf diese Daten gebe.
Die typische Argumentation dazu ist, dass sie sagen, man passt auf seine Kinder auf oder sowas. Das sind halt so die klassischen, du willst ja nur Gutes für diese Menschen tun, die du dann mit diesem Trojaner infizierst. Natürlich ein ultradreckiges Geschäftsmodell, was irgendwie auch in keiner Weise zu unterstützen ist. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich so, dass jetzt alleine aus dem Besitz eines solchen Trojaners zu folgern, dass es ein böser Mensch ist, ist dann halt schon eher schwierig.
Aber das ist ja genau das, was hier passiert ist. Die haben irgendwie mitgekriegt, der hat jemanden Trojaner gekauft und die sind erstmal dran.
Sagt man. Also das ist ja nun auch noch nicht so richtig klar, was da genau zu den Hausdurchsuchungen geführt hat. Es gibt halt einen Betroffenen oder einen angeblich Betroffenen, der sich in einem Forum zu Wort gemeldet hat und gesagt hat, hier bei mir war so eine Hausdurchsuchung, gibt es da noch mehr Betroffene von. Und ich habe das halt keineswegs für irgendwelche kriminelle Zwecke gekauft. Und die scheinen halt offenbar über irgendwelche Paypal-Abrechnungen auf ihn gestoßen zu sein. Was halt allerdings überhaupt nicht klar ist, ob das ein Fake ist, ob das irgendwie wirklich so ist, dass dieser Mensch sich da in diesem Forum auf die Art und Weise zu Wort gemeldet hat. Und es kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft tatsächlich, weiß ich, 100 Fälle hatte und tatsächlich nur 13 rausgepickt hat. Man weiß es halt einfach nicht. Und wenn es allerdings so ist, wie da so beschrieben wurde, dann haben die halt angeblich eben anhand dieser Paypal-Abrechnungen eine Hausturchsuchung durchgeführt auf dieser Basis.
Und jetzt zum juristischen Hintergrund. Was ist dieser Paragraph 202 C?
Das ist der sogenannte Hacker Tool Paragraph. Also das ist halt ein Paragraph, der eingeführt wurde als Strafgesetzbuch. Eigentlich ursprünglich als ein oder anderen Nachschlagparagraph. Also wenn du halt irgendwie eine Computerkriminalitätshandlung begehst und du benutzt dabei oder besitzt zu diesem Zweck halt spezialisierte Hacker Tools, dann gibt es noch mal zwei, drei Jahre oben drauf. So war halt die Intention dieses Paragraphen. Wir haben versucht, gegen ihn vorzugehen. Auch beim Bundesverfassungsgericht. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat aber abgelehnt, diesen Paragraphen zu kassieren mit der Begründung, dass er eben nur zum Zuge kommt, wenn eine kriminelle Intention vorliege. Die Idee war zu sagen, wir können jetzt nicht differenzieren, ob du dieses Tool besitzt, um Sicherheitsforschung zu betreiben oder irgendwie andere Leute anzugreifen. Deswegen soll er nur zur Anwendung kommen, so die Begründung in der Ablehnung des Verfassungsgerichts. Wenn klar ist, dass es eine kriminelle Intention vorliegt.
Also du musst erst mal beweisen, dass du nicht kriminell bist. Die Beweislastung wird umgekehrt und alle haben Spaß.
Langsam, langsam. Die Idee war, wenn wir nachweisen können, dass du kriminell aktiv bist und du diese Tools hast, dann bist du dran. Praktisch ist es aber so, wenn du so ein Ding hast, bist du verdächtig.
Ganz am Anfang war es so, dass die Ursprungsintention des Gesetzgebers aus dieser Cybercrime-Konvention kommt. Die wollten ursprünglich eigentlich all diese Tools illegalisieren. Dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass sie damit quasi die gesamte Security-Forschung ein bisschen illegalisieren und haben sich dann umgeschwenkt in der Begründung dieses Paragrafen zu sagen, wir wollen es nur, wenn eine kriminelle Intention vorliegt. Dementsprechend wurde dieser Paragraf extrem selten angewandt. Also ich glaube, seit seiner Einführung nur so ein paar Dutzend Mal oder so, ist ein sehr seltenes Delikt in der Kriminalstatistik. Und deswegen ist dieser Fall jetzt eben auch so bemerkenswert, weil es so einer der ersten Anwendungen wäre, wo man sagt, okay, der reine Besitz dieses Tools ohne Beweis einer kriminellen Intention dabei wird schon als Grundlage für Ermittlungen, Hausdurchsuchungen und so weiter und so fort benutzten. Deswegen ist dieser Fall heute auch so wichtig, weil wie gesagt, bisher war es größtenteils, bis auf sehr, sehr wenige Ausnahmen so, dass der erste Anwendung kam, wenn klar war, okay, da gibt es sowieso einen Computerkriminalitätsfall. Und dann suchen wir nochmal ein paar Grapfen, damit wir nochmal zwei Jahre mehr drauf packen können.
Aber ist das so, dass du gerade meintest, du musst jetzt eigentlich selber beweisen, dass du nicht kriminell bist?
Das wäre jetzt die Folge davon, wenn diese Hausdurchsuchungen und so weiter, die jetzt da gerade passieren, dann wäre es halt eine Änderung in der Interpretation dieses Paragrafen. Das ist halt das, was wir damals auch beklagt haben, was wir gesagt haben, so wie der Paragraf da im Gesetzbuch steht, lädt er dazu ein zu wügwürdiger Strafverfolgung. Weil er sozusagen so wie er im Gesetz steht, wenn du ihn buchstabengetreu interpretierst, reicht der reine Besitz eines Werkzeugs. Und nur in der Begründung des Gesetzes, auf die sich dann das Verfassungsgericht bezogen hat, steht halt drin, gemeint ist aber nur, wenn du halt eine kriminelle Intention hast.
Aber wie ist es denn für euch dann als Sicherheitsforscher, die ja alle ja böse Trojaner gekauft haben, wie ich gerade von euch erfahren habe, wollt ihr dann so eine Art Waffenschein einführen? So hier, ich bin berechtigt, ein Trojaner?
Das ist natürlich völliger Quatsch. Diese Diskussion gab es halt damals. Das kommt auch immer wieder hoch zu sagen, lizenzierte Sicherheitsforscher, so dieser ganze Kram. De facto wäre das eine massive Einschränkung der Handlungs- und Berufsfreiheit, die sicherlich verfassungsmäßig keinen Bestand hätte.
Das würde ja völlig verhindern, dass man so Sicherheit lernt, wie ihr das alle gemacht habt.
Genau, man kann sich da nicht als freischaffender Sicherheitsforscher reinbringen. Zumal es dann natürlich weitergeht. Weil dir so, wie dieser Paragraf da halt steht, ist ja auch für Umgehungswerkzeuge zum Beispiel zu benutzen. Umgehungswerkzeuge können so etwas wie Reverse Engineering Tools sein. Also Tools, mit denen man halt dekompilieren kann. Also das ist halt so...
Als eine Auslegungssache.
Genau, wie man es... Also man kann ihn, wenn man ihn bösartig auslegt, ist dieser Paragraf geeignet, irgendwie alles, was sich außerhalb der Anwendung von normalen, diesen Agreements, die man anklicken muss, wenn man so Software kauft, wie bewegt, zu illegalisieren, wenn man es halt ernst nimmt.
Okay, deine Frage auch zum Publikum?
Na aktuell wäre es dann ja auch der LYNX Text Browser, der kein JavaScript ausführt. Und deswegen den Ad-Blocker-Blocker nicht macht. Das wäre dann auch ein Tool zum Umgehen von Sicherheitsstunden.
In dem Fall ist das Urheberrecht dann eine Umgehung von digitalen Wörtern.
Das 202 ist immer nur Ausspähen von Daten und Veränderungen von Daten.
Also beziehst du dich jetzt gut mit der Chemologie.
Das, worauf du dich gerade beziehst, ist umgehen einer wirksamen Schutzmaßnahme.
Aber die Logik ist dieselbe.
Genau, die Logik ist dieselbe. Wenn ich Tools habe, die dann z.B. JavaScript nicht ausführen und deswegen der Passwortdialog nicht funktioniert auf einer Webseite, was ein völlig bescheuertes und unruhigermaßen Schutz wäre. Aber ich habe Tools, die sich nicht an das halten, was so normal ist. Und sind das dann plötzlich Hacker-Tools, die darunter fallen?
Also wie gesagt, muss man unterscheiden, was die gesetzliche Logik angeht, Umgebungstools versus Hacker-Tools. Aber klar ist halt, dass diese Logik zu versuchen, den IT-Nutzer auf allgemein konforme, vom Hersteller intendierte Nutzung zu beschränken, steckt natürlich dahinter. Also zu sagen, wer macht denn schon sowas? Das können doch bloß böse sein. Du kannst doch bloß eine böse Intention haben, wenn du solche Werkzeuge besitzt. Es ist halt so, wie wenn sie dich auf der Straße anhalten, und du hast Lockpicking-Tools dabei. So deren Idee davon. Und denen dann zu erklären, die Hälfte meiner Freunde hat Lockpicking-Tools dabei, weil es halt praktisch ist, wenn man wieder vor einer verschlossenen Tür steht. Diese Logik verstehen die halt sehr schwer.
Gibt es denn jetzt irgendwie den Willen, vom Clubhouse noch mal politisch was gegenzumachen? Oder die sitzt man jetzt erstmal abwarten und guckt?
Der Punkt ist halt, dieser 202C ist uns schon lange natürlich ein Dorn am Auge, weil er hängt halt wie so ein Damoklesschwert über halt dem, ja, allem, was wir so tun und machen. Deswegen sind wir damals halt auch vor das Fastensgericht gezogen und haben halt versucht, das irgendwie da abzubiegen. Mittlerweile ist es halt schwieriger geworden, das zu ändern. So, weil halt natürlich Zeit ins Land gestrichen ist und man halt jetzt eine völlig neue Argumentation braucht. Allerdings ist es halt so, dass natürlich, insbesondere halt in diesem Computerstrafrecht, da gibt es halt relativ häufig Novellen der Gesetze. Also da gibt es halt irgendwie so alle drei, vier Jahre, fassen sie das wieder an, um es halt irgendwie an die aktuelle Zeit anzupassen und jeweils dann gibt es halt eine Chance, da halt auch Sachen zu kippen. Und klar ist halt auch, dass der, also das insbesondere jetzt der Weg ist, halt Grundsatzurteile zu erstreiten, die halt sicherstellen, dass die Interpretation dieses Paragrafen halt eben nicht, also der Abverwandteil...
Aber heißt das mal, müsste ich jetzt so sagen, juristisch gegen diese Durchsuchung vorgehen?
Ich denke, das wird sich dann wohl darauf hinaus bewegen. Ja, also mindestens irgendwie, wenn es denn da zum Verfahren kommt, gegen Durchsuchung alleine vorzugehen, ist meistens schwierig. Aber mindestens wenn es da halt ein Verfahren gibt, dann muss man halt dein Grundsatzurteil einstreben.
Problematisch wird es halt vor allen Dingen dann, wenn halt so eine Durchsuchung erst mal stattfindet, bei jemandem, der das tatsächlich eben aus Forschungszwecken gekauft oder erworben hat und vielleicht sogar auch irgendwie bei sich benutzt. Die Person oder eben der Sicherheitsforscher oder diese Sicherheitsfirma, die muss sich dann erst mal mit dem ganzen Prozedere einer Hausdurchsuchung auseinandersetzen. Da werden wahrscheinlich Arbeitsgeräte beschlagnahmt. Und auch wenn am Ende die Staatsanwaltschaft die nicht mehr ermittelt und die Anzeige zurücknimmt und so weiter, dieser Stress bleibt und auch irgendwie dieses ganze Risiko, was dann damit verbunden ist, wenn die Rechner erst mal einkassiert wurden.
Also das weiß man wahrscheinlich, wenn eine Hausdurchsuchung, wenn die Rechner bestarkt werden, kann das Jahre dauern, bis man die wiederbekommt. Also die sind dann quasi praktisch, sind die erst mal weg. Und dann kann man das vielleicht einmal nochmal neu kaufen. Aber spielst du es beim zweiten Mal, wird es dann irgendwie haarig.
Also du musst deinem Anwalt mehr bezahlen, um dir die Kisten wieder zu bringen als neue Rechner kosten.
Also das Wertproblem ist ja gar nicht so das Problem, sondern mehr, dass du eben arbeitsunfähig bist und dadurch einen ganz anderen Verlust hast und eben auch deine Kunden nicht bedienen kannst usw. Also das ist schon ziemlich übel. Macht Backup von eurer Hardware.
Die nehmen sie ja auch nicht.
Macht Offside-Bags ab.
Macht verschlüsselte Offside-Bags ab.
Genau. Das Grundübel von diesen Paragrafen 202c ist, dass man davon ausgeht, dass Software überhaupt so einen intendierten Anwendungszweck hat und dass sich dadurch irgendwie die Vorbereitung des Ausspähens von Daten überhaupt manifestieren könnte. Ein Tool, was wir alle die ganze Zeit nutzen, ist zum Beispiel Wireshark, was Netzwerktraffic sichtbar macht. Auch den von anderen Netzwerkteilnehmern unter gewissen Umständen. Und da wird jeder, der in irgendeinem Netzwerk auch nur arbeitet oder Tests macht, da muss man nicht mal was mit Security zu tun haben, arbeitet die ganze Zeit mit diesem Tool. Das ist aber natürlich auch das Tool, was ich benutze, wenn ich irgendwie im Hotel 20 Euro fürs WLAN bezahlen soll und das aber nicht bereit bin zu zahlen. Das heißt, da begehe ich dann vielleicht eine Straftat oder mache irgendwas falsch. Jetzt könnte man den Wireshark Leuten sagen, die sind mitschuldig, weil sie mir dieses Tool zur Verfügung gestellt haben. Diese Geräte, diese Tools haben eben immer wieder andere Anwendungsmöglichkeiten und es lässt sich auch nicht von vornherein sagen, dass egal, welche Software du jemandem gibst, nur für diesen Zweck einsetzbar ist. Also ich kann mit Microsoft Word erpresser Briefe schreiben. Deswegen ist Microsoft nicht schuld daran. Also so weit gehen bei Basis-Tools die Anwendungszwecke tatsächlich auseinander. Und deswegen natürlich würden wir uns alle vorstellen, dass es irgendwie sinnvoll wäre, kriminelle Anwendungen von solchen Tools zu verbieten und gleichzeitig die Tools schön in schwarz und weiß zu teilen. Und das geht eben nicht, weil es einen riesigen Graubereich gibt, wie du bestimmte Tools anwenden kannst. Und natürlich kannst du Metasploit nehmen und dir irgendwie einen Basic-Trojaner zusammenschustern und den irgendwie deiner Freundin auf ihren Windows-Rechner schieben. Kannste machen, geht.
Sollte aber nicht.
Sollte nicht. Und das Wichtige ist, da die Grenze zu ziehen, wo du es machst und nicht da die Grenze zu ziehen, wo du dir Metasploit runterlädst oder einen Trojaner baust und dir Wissen darüber aneignest oder Metasploit der Menschheit zur Verfügung stellt.
Man kommt natürlich trotzdem zu den Feinheiten, also diese Leute, die diese Android-Trojaner über die wir gesprochen haben, da will man ja eigentlich schon unterstellen, die verkaufen jetzt nicht aus guten, also nicht nur an Sicherheitsvorschriften, die verkaufen das ja, also die machen daraus ein Verkaufsmodell, weil halt tatsächlich Leute das irgendwie ihrem Freund Freundin aufs Handy spielen wollen. Was macht man mit denen?
Ich sage mal so, ich wehre jetzt nicht dagegen Leuten, die Werkzeuge, die explizit mit dem Ziel vermarktet werden, andere Leute auszuspionieren, denen halt auf den Pelz zu rücken, auch heuristisch. Also egal, ob sie die jetzt exportieren in irgendwelche Regime oder ob sie die halt so bewerben nach dem Motto hier, kannst du deine Freunde ausspionieren, in dem Augenblick ist deren Intention ja klar. Also in dem Augenblick ist ja klar, was sie eigentlich wollen. Ist jetzt was anderes als ein Sicherheitsforscher, der halt irgendwie einen Export schreibt und den publiziert oder auch einen Hersteller verkauft. Wenn man hingeht und sagt, ok, hier ist ein Werkzeug und dieses Werkzeug ist geschrieben, beworben, intendiert, im Handbuch dokumentiert als Werkzeug für Spionage. Ja Gott, also da hab ich jetzt überhaupt nichts dagegen, wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft denen auf den Pelz rückt. Also dem Verkäufer.
Ja, aber nicht den Leuten, die das kaufen. Das sagt lange nichts über die kriminelle Energie der Käufer aus.
Correct.
Ok, jetzt haben wir viel gelernt über das Security-Business. Ich würde jetzt noch so gerne eine kleine Abschlussrunde machen wollen und das würde noch mal zu den Anfängen zurückkommen wollen. Und von jedem von euch noch mal fragen wollen. Wenn man sich jetzt in die Sendung gehört und denkt so, ok, das ist nicht ganz so glamourös und ich darf tatsächlich nicht immer eine schwarze Skimasket tragen, aber ich interessiere mich vielleicht trotzdem dafür. Aber Hoodie. Ich interessiere mich vielleicht trotzdem dafür. Wo fängt man am besten wie an? Was liest man? Was würdet ihr empfehlen? Wie steigt man da rein? Naja, sag mal ein konkretes Beispiel. Was soll man sich mal angucken?
Standards lesen. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, man möchte das IT-System auf Sicherheit überprüfen, hilft es halt ungemein, die RFCs zu lesen und sich an den RFCs zu orientieren, um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie Sachen aufgebaut sein sollen, wie sie spezifiziert sind und dann halt dementsprechend auch danach prüfen.
Also ich würde tatsächlich eher Exploits lesen.
Du hast eine andere Herangehensweise, ja.
Tatsächlich eher sagen, okay, also die weniger masochistische. Genau, also davon lernen, wie andere Leute das Thema kaputt gemacht haben. Aber es gibt ja halt die...
Wie kommt man da gefahrfrei eigentlich rein?
Also es gibt einen sehr einfachen Weg. Es gibt halt die sogenannten CVEs, das sind halt irgendwie die veröffentlichten Fehler im System. Und die beschreiben zumindest erstmal grob, wie dieser Fehler funktioniert. Also was ist ich irgendwie? Unchecked Memory oder sonst irgendwas. Was halt immer diese Art und Weise ist, wie dieser Fehler auszunutzen ist. Und in vielen Fällen ist es dann halt eben so, dass man zum Beispiel zu so was wie Metasploit gehen kann, wo dann halt zu diesen High-Level Beschreibungen, wie dieser Fehler zustande kam und wie er auszunutzen ist, eben auch das Source Code zu finden ist. Also dann kannst du einfach gehen und ein Metasploit-Modul dazu laden, dir den Source Code angucken, das mal ausprobieren, mal die Situation nachstellen, mal gucken, wie es funktioniert. Und davon halt lernen. Also danach einfach lernen. Viel ist halt eben die Erfahrung zu bauen oder aufzubauen, wie solche Sachen typischerweise kaputt gehen, wie sie typischerweise ausgenutzt werden. Ganz viele Sachen sind halt heutzutage auch Kombinations-Exploits. Also wenn du halt irgendwie diese Technik, diese Technik und diese Technik kombinierst, kommst du auch um diese Sicherheitsmaßnahmen drum rum. Oder unter diesen unwahrscheinlichen Umständen schaffst du es halt trotzdem so.
Also ich muss nochmal, ich will die Frage nochmal im Detail stellen, weil ich stelle mir vor, wenn ich jetzt sage, mich als interessierter totaler neuer Anfänger irgendwie als Internet-Wergeber und Google hier Seite zu Seite exploits, dann komme ich sehr schnell auf irgendwie shady Dinge. Dieses Metasploit ist sozusagen auch so dieser Werkzeugkasten halt, den man sich gefahrlos angucken kann, also ohne zu sagen, gleich, okay, sehr gut.
Also ich würde vielleicht sogar, also ich würde mir noch einen einfacheren Einstieg suchen und mich den Paralympics der IT-Security zuwenden, wie sie von Mario Heiderich immer genannt werden, nämlich den Web-Security-Sachen. Weil man da relativ einfache Sprachen hat, relativ einfache Angriffsmöglichkeiten und sich einfach mal so ein altes WordPress runterzuladen und zu schauen, wie krieg ich da jetzt eine SQL-Injection hin. Das ist ziemlich abgedroschen, aber das zeigt einem eigentlich relativ viel darüber, wo Systeme, quasi in dem Fall eine Datenbank und ein PHP-Skript, wie die miteinander interagieren und vor allem immer wieder darauf zurückzukommen, dass man natürlich immer Systeme da hackt, wo sie Input entgegennehmen. Und sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, wie verarbeitet dieses System mein Input und was ist Input, was dieses System nicht erwartet. Erwartet ist irgendwie vielleicht nicht so großen Input oder erwartet ist, wenn ich hinschreibe, der Input ist klein und ich gebe ihm aber großen, kommt es damit zurecht. Also sich einfach so zu überlegen, welches nicht erwartete Input kann ich dem System geben, was es im Zweifelsfall aus dem Tritt bringt. Und so eine SQL-Injection ist da immer noch relativ einfach umzusetzen. Und da lernt man glaube ich am ehesten auch einerseits, wie einfach sowas teilweise funktionieren kann und wie schwierig es ist, sowas zu verhindern.
Noch eine Frage aus dem Publikum.
Eine Ergänzung, es gibt auch wunderbare Webseiten im Netz, wo man sich so durchklicken kann und so Sachen ausprobieren kann, die dafür gemacht sind. Das sind dann so Online-Kurse, also nicht jetzt auf irgendeine Webseite losgehen, da kann man Ärger kriegen. Und ansonsten gibt es Capture the Flag-Wettbewerbe, wenn man da irgendwie mitmachen möchte. Es gibt oft irgendwo lokale Gruppen, die an sowas teilnehmen. Da kann man auch einfach mal hingehen und sich das angucken. Vorher mit den Leuten reden, die freuen sich meistens über Besuch. Haben wir auch in Berlin an der TU zum Beispiel so eine Gruppe, die relativ gefährlich ist. Und ansonsten halt diese Webseiten, die erklären das auch. Und da kann man so einen kleinen Contest machen und sich da durcharbeiten.
Oder selber was bauen, ans Internet hängen und gucken, wie es aufgemacht wurde.
Dann gucken, dass du nicht plötzlich Trittbett wirst. Da musst du wirklich gucken, dass das dann nicht so, wenn du das Wochenende weg bist, plötzlich dann den Server komplett killt oder so.
Okay, jetzt würde ich gerne sagen, diese Webseiten, die du gerade erwähnt hast, wo man sie hinkriegen kann, das wäre schön, wenn du die in die Shownotes eintragen könntest, damit der geneigte Hörer das auch vielleicht nachschlagen kann. THS, hast du noch berühmte letzte Worte?
Nö, ich finde die Sache mit den Webseiten, das ist halt durchaus eine Sache, wo man einen guten Einstieg finden kann. Und was vor allen Dingen auch der echten Welt entspricht und nicht ganz so theoretisch ist. Aber das mit den CTF-Challenges wollte ich auch anbringen, weil es gibt halt A, Gruppen, die sich treffen und das so trainieren. Und halt auch irgendwie Neuankömmlinge erzählen, was sie da machen können. Und es gibt halt die Challenges von den Wettbewerben und so weiter auch noch zum Runterladen im Netz. Das heißt, man bekommt halt Programme und irgendwelche Dinge, die man halt tatsächlich auch hacken kann. Also das ist halt natürlich Teil dieser Challenge, dass man sie auch irgendwie hacken und knacken kann. Und in der Regel decken diese Challenges ja schon einen großen Teil der Real-World-Beispiele so ab. Also von daher ist das kein so schlechter Einstieg. Ich persönlich würde halt den Leuten aber auch dazu raten, wenn ihr euch wirklich damit auseinandersetzen wollt, was halt auch neu ist, dann schaut euch halt auch einfach mal was Neues an und versucht das von vorneherein zu verstehen. Also ich meine, wo es halt irgendwie Low-Hanging-Fruits gibt, ist halt tatsächlich in diesem Internet-of-Things-Bereich. Geht einfach mal irgendwo hin und kauft euch vier WLAN-Steckdosen und schaut einfach mal, was da drin steckt, ob man da Daten auslesen kann. Und so kann man halt auch Stück für Stück teilweise neue Sachen lernen. Und wenn ihr zum ersten Mal den Lötkolben in die Hand nehmt und irgendein Arduino an irgendein Speicherchip anlötet, dann ist das halt auch schon mal ein echter Gewinn für diese. Man sieht halt auch, dass da was passiert, dass da halt ein Lerneffekt einsetzt und so weiter. Von daher kann ich das eigentlich nur empfehlen, sich nicht immer nur auf die Sachen zu konzentrieren, die andere schon bewiesen haben, dass sie machbar sind, sondern halt auch wirklich einfach den Mut zu haben und zu sagen, ich setz mich jetzt einfach mal hier ran und beiß mich da halt ein paar Wochen durch. Und dann kommt man da auch zu einem Ergebnis.
Okay, und jetzt hab ich noch eine allerallerletzte Frage mit einer Bitte um kurze Antwort an meine vier Gäste. Und das ist, Frank hat es schon gesagt, eine Orchideensfürchter ist, wenn irgendein Alter tief immer zu lange in dem Beruf ist. Was würdet ihr machen, wenn ihr nicht mehr in der Security-Branche arbeitet, Frank? Tatsächlich Orchideen?
Tja, ich glaube, ich würde irgendwas machen, was mehr mit Atomen als mit Bits zu tun hat, so ganz Porsche, also mehr so Dinge, die mit physischer Hardware, also vielleicht Roboter oder sowas.
Also ich habe ja so eine Zeit hinter mir, wo ich mich mal von den Computern gelöst habe und den Menschen zugewandt habe. Und als ich dann mit dem Psychologiestudium fertig war, habe ich mir dann auch echt wieder gedacht, vielleicht doch lieber Computer.
Wir gehen dann noch mal zusammen studieren und machen ein Diplom Holzwirt.
Alles klar.
Holzwirt ist doch eine super Sache.
Sehr schön, also doch euch Ideen und Holz. Wunderbar, das war die Sendung Chaosradio 2017 über professionelle Hacker. Wir ziehen uns jetzt alle wieder unsere Skimützen auf. Vielen Dank an Frank, Linus, Sebas und TAS, die Gäste waren. Vielen Dank an Peter, der sich das Thema ausgedacht hat. Vielen Dank an Dalimo, der einen Großteil der Orga gemacht hat und viel fluchen musste. Vielen Dank an Mutags, der Kamerakind war und viele Fragen gestellt hat. Und Wettervogel, der den Sound so geregelt hat, dass ihr uns auch alle hören konntet. Ihr könnt diese Sendung runtergeladen haben unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Ihr könnt auch Fragen oder Vorschläge, Themenvorstellungen geschicken an chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und alles, was mir jetzt noch zu sagen bleibt, ist, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Offside-Backups.
Tschüss!
How much weed they drink.